Hey everybody,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by legal
zoom.
Legal Zoom is a way to handle all sorts of legal shit that you would have to
actually go to a lawyer to lawyer to handle it online on your own with no
clothes on.
And you can go to legal zoom.com and you can incorporate or form an LLC for as
little as 99 bucks.
You could form a will for 69 bucks.
It's really easy to do.
And you,
if you panic and you're freaking out and you're like,
I think I'm gonna go to jail,
they will connect you with an independent attorney who can give you additional
guidance independent.
It's not like one of their guys.
Um,
and legal zoom is not a law firm,
but they provide you self help services at your specific direction and it can
save you a lot of time and a lot of money.
They've helped millions of people in America.
In fact,
over the last 12 years,
2 million Americans have used legal zoom and they've saved a ton of money.
It's a suite service.
It's way better and way more stress free than actually going to a lawyer.
And if you enter in the code Rogan in the referral box at checkout,
you'll save yourself some money doing that.
So check it out.
Legal zoom.com use the code word Rogan and we're also brought to you by
stamps.com stamps.com is an awesome service.
If you have shit that you're sending from your house and you would have to like
weigh it and measure it,
especially if you have her own business.
If you have your own business like it's a huge pain in the ass,
you have to send things out,
you have to go to the mailbox and they have to weigh things.
You can do all that yourself and you can actually print out real legit us
postage right from your desk.
They will give you a digital scale.
If you enter in the code,
J e r e for your special offer,
that's a no risk Twat,
no risk,
no risk trial.
$110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So go to stamps.com and before you do anything,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in j r II.
It's a sweet way to do business.
All you have to do is print everything up,
put it on the boxes yourself,
hand it to the post man and you're done.
When you like that in your life,
I would as well.
stamps.com Code Word J.
R e.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N n.
I.
T.
A.
If you haven't been there for awhile,
checkout some of the new things that we have,
including the Zombie kettlebells and the primal bells.
There's four in a series of each one now,
uh,
ranging from in the primal bells.
We have little howler monkeys that are 18 pounds all the way up to gorillas,
which is 72 pounds.
Um,
I always emphasize,
I mean,
if you're in a room,
if you think they're cool and you just want to have more on your house,
that's one thing.
But if you actually going to work out with them,
if you can hire a trainer,
just hire just for maybe one time,
see if he'll let you like film them on a,
on an iPhone and just get the technique right and don't start with a really
heavyweight.
Don't try to go match all you'll hurt yourself and it's such a stupid way to
hurt yourself.
You could get a serious legit workout with like 35 pounds and I know you like
Joe.
I'm way more manly than that.
I know you are.
I am too,
but yet I can get an awesome workout in with 35 pounds.
You'd be,
you'd be seriously impressed and you're way better off going light and doing it
correctly.
We sell DVDs on them like the Keith Weber Kettle Bell Cardio extreme,
a workout DVDs one and two.
They're fantastic.
It's a great thing to do.
You just do what he does,
like just,
he said,
ready,
go.
And he does it with you.
So it's like it,
it forces you to do some shit that you would ordinarily,
you would stop,
you would quit.
You'd take a breather but he's not breathing so you're not going to either your,
you're going to go through with it.
There's a bunch of them.
We have a bunch of packages for sale.
Um,
there's,
there's the two extreme kettlebell cardio DVDs from Keith Webber,
but uh,
we also have some instructionals on how to work out with club bells,
which we also sell.
What we're trying to do is sell all things that work for what you would call
functional strength.
Like there's a lot of exercises that people do at the gym that they don't really
enhance her athleticism or functional strength,
meaning they don't really translate into sports.
They just make your biceps bigger.
And if that's all you want to do,
that's fine,
but this can do that as well.
And it will really translate into a actual physical performance.
Uh,
we have tons of supplements and if you use a code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
that's on a.com.
O.
N.
I.
T.
Anna's here.
We get the party started.
All right.
If the music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
try by day Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
Thank you for joining us.
Thank you for having me.
Very excited.
Kasparian yes.
Can announce it from the young Turks,
which is,
you guys are like the new media,
right?
And this is like old media and there's new meats.
Yeah.
Establishment media,
new media.
I'm actually working on a book about it.
Um,
I mean I'm not 100% sure that it's going to be published,
so I don't want to give too many details.
It's,
it's worth something I'm working on now.
Um,
but I got to experience that transition from establishment media to new media
and there are really important differences and just this whole media revolution
that's happening,
that's really exciting for anyone who's interested in journalism.
And I mean,
you're part of it with this podcast,
allegedly,
you are,
you are allegedly,
and it's a,
it's a,
it's a really great way for people who want to be heard without being censored.
You know,
I can basically say anything I want on March my show without worrying about
anyone telling me,
hey,
you can't say this,
you can't say that.
We have corporate sponsors.
We got to make sure the advertisers,
you know,
continue giving us
what's fascinating is all you have to do is be interesting,
entertaining,
informative,
and that's it.
It doesn't have to have CNN on it or Fox on it or any of these other names that
we've attributed.
So like meaning what the news is,
where the news comes from.
Definitely.
I mean,
when I first started working at Tyt,
it was this unknown show.
It had been around for a few years,
um,
but it was a really big risk for me to work there because I was working at CBS
radio at the time and CBS radio had like a very clear path for me.
You start off as an assistant producer,
your work,
you will work your way up and if you're good enough and persistent enough,
you'll be an anchor and you'll be fine.
You know,
you'll be set for life.
Um,
with TYT,
it was just this huge risk because it was unknown.
I didn't know if it would survive at the time it was on this radio station
called Air America.
I don't know if you heard of it.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
The folks at t y t stands for the young Turks.
The young Turks.
You're on a plane with no Google and you're like,
what the fuck is?
Um,
so I just remember being really unhappy at CBS feeling like,
you know,
even if I get to the top of the ladder within this company,
I'm not going to feel fulfilled doing what they're doing.
Um,
and the first day I worked at the young Turks,
um,
I heard Janky Yeager,
the main hosts of the show go on this rant against the Bush administration and
some of the ridiculous,
you know,
civil liberty violations,
a civil liberties violations that they were accused of guilty of,
not,
not even accused of.
And I was like,
wow,
you do not see this in the media.
You don't see this type of honesty.
You don't see people go off like that.
They're usually very senatorial.
Whenever they're doing any type of commentary.
And I was tired of it.
I wanted some real news coverage.
So that's why I made the decision that I made and I,
and I left and thank God I made that decision cause TYT actually succeeded in
big ways.
In what year do you think it was where you know,
it started to shift because it seems like to me it's uh,
maybe three,
five,
whatever years it is.
But within the last few years,
there's this shift where my friends don't ever talk to me about what they saw on
CNN.
They don't want to talk to me what they saw on Fox News.
It's always,
I read this online,
I watch this online,
I saw the young Turks,
I'd watched this show,
I watched this guy's podcast and this guy said,
I mean everybody that I talked to is,
is talking about stuff that they're getting when they're talking about real
issues.
There's talking about stuff they're getting online.
Yeah,
well a lot of things have changed.
People don't rush home to watch a newscast anymore.
And people also know that there are corporate interests involved in traditional
media.
You know,
you see advertisements for things that you can't even buy on traditional media.
Like I see advertisements for this company called Siemens and I'm like,
what are they trying to sell me?
And you realize that they're not trying to sell the consumer anything.
It's a form of control over the network.
BP has a bunch of advertisements on mainstream media and if they are the people
that are paying your bills,
you are less to be critical of their business practices.
So with,
with traditional media you have that issue.
And I think people are now more and more aware of it.
And with online media it's on demand.
Okay.
It's raw.
We,
cause we say whatever the hell we want without worrying about censorship and
people like that.
There's something really refreshing about it.
You know,
they didn't have it before and they didn't think they could and they thought if
they did it probably would come in and uneducated form exactly.
Be Some idiots or saying stupid things that don't even ring true.
But instead there's intelligent people and they're like,
fuck this.
And you're like,
Whoa,
hold on.
Yeah.
Like these people are actually articulate.
They look like they went to school.
Like this is,
this is,
you know,
and this is a new thing.
I actually think that it's a perfect example of the free market deciding because
I don't think that the American people are stupid.
I think that they can detect,
decide and determine whether or not someone is intelligent enough or credible
enough to cover a particular story.
So a perfect example of that is I'm not a science reporter.
So whenever I attempt to cover science news,
uh,
the audience tears me apart for it as they should because that's not my
expertise.
My expertise is political commentary,
um,
social commentary.
And that's usually the stuff that does really well on the young Turks when I
cover it.
Um,
and so the audience decides and they will let you know.
With mainstream media,
it's really difficult for you to voice your opinion if you don't like the
coverage.
Right?
You might write an email,
but you don't know if anyone's ever going to see it.
With our show,
we're on youtube,
we get constant,
constant feedback and a lot of times it's not construct
diff,
uh,
but,
but sometimes it is constructed
be the lowest form of human on the planet is the Youtube commentor pretty
hideous people on there.
If you looked at it like per numbers,
like per capita,
it's got a lovely 40% assets.
Okay.
So let me give you an example of something that enraged me the other day.
I literally lost it in our studio and everyone's like,
you need to calm down.
We covered this story about this guy in Massachusetts who was going around
taking up skirt pictures with his cell phone.
Okay?
So cops finally caught him back in 2010 and now he's going to stand trial for it
and he's actually suing the government because he feels that his first amendment
rights have been violated and his female lawyer is arguing that since these
women are in a public place,
they have no reasonable expectation of privacy.
Therefore he should be allowed to take up skirt pictures of them.
How absurd is that argument?
Anyway,
we covered on the show.
We share our opinion on it and I would say like about one third of the audience
was like,
yeah,
they're right.
Yeah.
And as a dumb bitch what is,
she doesn't know anything first amendment rights and it's like Ah,
what am I supposed to do with these types of situations?
It's really frustrating.
That's in those women who are lawyers or gangster.
Listen,
that's some gangster shit right there.
She just likes the trader Shit right there.
Yeah,
I would,
I'd be very curious to see if she would be okay with this dude with her own
client taking up skirt pictures with her or have her.
Um,
and another argument she made was what,
I mean,
all these women were wearing underwear.
We didn't see their badge so it's okay.
Wow.
That's very gangster of her.
Yeah,
that's is that just what happens when you get into the business world?
You get into the corporate world and you,
you know,
you become a lawyer and you're just,
it's about winning and losing and definitely on the client and just argue it
even though your sold your own vagina.
I know.
Hold her own vagina.
I don't know what she looks like,
but maybe she has nothing to worry about.
Maybe no one wants to get an obscured picture of her.
And that's why she has no problem making these arguments in court.
Or maybe she's just dying for someone to get a picture of where maybe that could
be it too.
Definitely.
Yeah,
it's so that's a fucking big leap that those women lawyers made.
They just decided it's fucking straight to hell.
I was really surprised by that.
But you know,
look,
when you have,
um,
there's like financial gain involved,
then okay,
I guess I can kind of understand where you're coming from,
your lawyer and you're trying to make some money I guess.
And it's really difficult for lawyers right now to even get cases to get work.
So maybe that plays a role in it.
But what really bothered me about it is we have a progressive audience.
Like our audience is pretty liberal.
So whenever I see that kind of responds to a story like that,
I'm always shocked.
I'm like,
wait,
you guys are okay with this?
It's just men,
men who are most men who are raised by shitheads.
That's a lot of it.
It's a big part of it.
The real problem is they don't even realize they're being shitheads cause their
dad was a shithead.
Their brothers or Shithead,
they grow up in a community of shitheads.
They don't even realize it.
It's just,
it's just a behavior.
And there's also a possibility that they're just straight out trolling.
Like they don't even believe what they're saying,
but they're doing it to get a response like this.
I just think just one,
they just one and I'm totally aware of that,
but I just,
yeah.
And I remember,
I remember being in the studio,
like reading the comments and I was like,
what the fuck?
Why?
What am I doing with my life?
Does it matter?
Does it,
you know?
And I started feeling really bad about it,
but then I was like,
you just can't let that stuff get to you.
You gotta take it with a grain of salt.
Yeah,
you can get caught up in an online troll war.
You guys actually made fun of me,
the young Turks tip because I got an online my space thing.
I don't even remember that a long time ago,
but he was right.
I would've made fun of me if I was making,
I showed them,
we had this interaction with this kid.
This kid got kept harassing me over and over again.
It was during the myspace days and you know,
no one knew like how to handle that yet.
It was like the new thing,
if someone could just contact people and so some people would just contact
people and go,
why have you not killed yourself?
You know,
just,
and you would get an email from someone saying,
you know,
you're horrible.
You should,
you know,
you should eat glass,
whatever.
You'd get like a lot of those in a day.
The fuck.
Like this is weird.
This is a new thing.
Interesting.
I get um,
Dick pics regularly,
really regularly geotag
them and you shouldn't put them re upload them online.
Let know where that sweet dick is
high.
I've considered that.
But you know,
a lot of times they'll send me the pictures on Facebook because I have a fan
page on Facebook and every once in a while check the messages and they're so
stupid because all of their private information is on there.
Like where they work,
who their girlfriend or their wife is and part of me wants to like forward it
over to their girlfriend or wife,
but I'm too nice like I don't want to like ruin their lives over there like
perverted behavior.
Well that's very kind of you.
Yeah,
do that.
Didn't the guy recently lose his job because they found out he was,
yeah,
he was a Reddit troll would do evil evil shit on reddit and some people said,
all right,
who is this guy?
And then they found,
you know who this guy was and it was a character that he was playing like to
blow off steam.
He was allegedly,
he would just be like really evil and nasty online.
Yes.
Small part of me felt kind of bad for him because he had a family to take care
of and you know it's going to like destroy his life and I get it online
anonymity allows people to blow off steam in that way.
And a lot of people right now because of the economic crisis,
because of all the crap that's going on in the government,
all the death and destruction that's around us constantly.
A lot of people need some sort of outlet and so they will use online anonymity
to do that,
to say hideous things to other people because that makes them feel good about
themselves.
And I think that if you're a mature adult you can just ignore them and step
away.
I'm not interested in censoring them.
I know that youtube is trying to like,
you know,
work with their comments so those negative comments get pushed back to the
bottom or whatever and no one can read them.
I just feel like,
you know,
the Internet should be an open forum for the most hateful people if they want to
be hateful and we as adults have to have thicker skin.
And just walk away and not let it get,
get to us and it's hard to do.
It still gets to me.
I mean that's what I opened the show with.
You know,
I like the way you two handles it.
If too many people say this comments retarded than they,
they eliminate it.
But you can always see it if you wanted to like show the comment.
Yeah,
you could still show the comment.
They're slowly getting rid of anonymity where they're,
you know,
attaching the comments to a Google plus account.
So it will be easier to identify who that person is.
Um,
I'm not necessarily against that.
I just feel like,
you know,
I don't want to move closer towards censorship online.
I love that it's an open forum even though there are negative aspects to it that
impact my life.
Yeah,
no,
I agree with you.
I think it's a,
it's an important like method of criticism that was never available before.
We have a very honest view of like what you do and what people like,
what you,
when they like,
what you do when they don't.
And even if it's like really hyper critical overcritical if they have a point
like that point probably would have never gotten to you during any other era.
Like if you want to like really analyze what you're doing and try to figure out
like what's the best way to hone this and they'll give you a lot of input.
They definitely will.
I will say that my political views have changed since I started working at TYT
and it's not necessarily because of my colleagues.
Um,
it has a lot to do with audience feedback.
For instance,
you know what I thought about prostitution when I first started,
it was very different from what I think now.
I was definitely against legalizing prostitution.
I was in favor of tough on crime legislation when it came to dealing with that.
And then I realized like this is stupid.
It's not keeping anyone safe.
Um,
people were getting hurt as a result of,
you know,
pushing this ban against prostitution.
So I've changed my views on that.
I think that we should legalize it and regulate it because that'll create a safe
environment.
And that's just one example of many
Willie d from the Geto boys said it best.
He said you got to let a whole be a Ho.
I mean,
if you have two consenting adults wanting to do that,
exchanged money for sex,
why the hell not?
It's amazing that we have like this huge porn industry in the country and as
long as they do it in front of a camera,
it's totally fine.
But if they do it behind the scenes,
it's illegal.
Well,
it's also weird that you can have sex with anybody you want for free and
nothing.
There's no crime committed at all.
But if money's exchanged,
somehow you become a criminal bullet parties.
Does anyone really have sex for free though?
When you really think about it?
[inaudible] I didn't want to know this about you.
I think a,
yeah,
this is people that,
there's people where it evens out.
Where it's free on both sides.
No,
no,
but what I mean by that is usually there's something else involved.
I'm not talking about money,
right?
But there are emotions involved.
There's an exchange of emotions.
There's an exchange of something
need to get rid of fluids.
True.
Yeah.
Well,
you know there's,
there's obviously there's massive issues with men versus women as far as how the
emotionally connect sex and and also the the need,
like what?
I don't know what it's like to need Sachs as a woman and I'm sure it's a very
specific itch whereas with a male I,
I'm pretty sure after all my years of observing men and women in the difference,
that is a different animal.
I think the horniness for a man is very intoxicating and fogging and confusing
and I don't know if it is for women.
I think that's why like a lot of women,
like a few cocktails first,
they can light up the crazy furnace without
I think,
I think the cocktails,
I think men and women have similar sexual desires.
However,
women are not allowed to be as open about it because of societal expectations
and certain gender roles.
If you are a woman who is open about how much you love sex and how often you
want to have sex and how badly you need it,
you are looked at as a Ho.
There's no question about it.
People will refer to you as a loose woman,
a slutty woman.
That's the reason why a lot of women like to have the cocktails before they have
sex because that'll allow them to let loose and do what they really want to do.
Right.
You know,
without feeling guilty about it.
Um,
at least that's my,
my take.
And then also if you don't have sex,
if you decide to save yourself for marriage or are you safe,
save yourself or someone that you genuinely love or whatever,
then you're considered a prude.
There's really no winning.
Yeah.
Women have a total short anesthetic society and society wise when it comes to
sex,
without a doubt.
But I think that if you wanted to say like who's going to think that you're a
hoe for enjoying sex?
While it's definitely going to be women,
it's going to be a lot of women that think you're a Ho and it's definitely going
to be guys who you won't have sex with.
Right?
Right.
So what's left?
The only left with like two groups of guys.
There's guys that would have zero problem with it at all and then there's guys
that would only have a problem with it if you weren't attracted to them.
That's you know,
and most likely see it weeds out assholes.
So if you were a chick and you were just like,
listen,
I'm a freak.
I like to get fucked all day long.
That's what I'm into.
You'll find exactly the right people that you need in your life.
That's an interesting perspective.
I think girls won't want to have anything to do with you.
I know,
but you'll also attract a lot of really scary pervy people.
Oh no doubt.
Instantly.
Because I think,
I think for a lot of people,
especially in the culture we're living right now,
if you're that open about your sexual desires,
you know,
people will see that as a green light to do things that might even be considered
illegal,
you know,
whether it's harassment or sexual assault or something.
That's true.
And also,
I mean this is like probably a bullshit,
but I would,
I would imagine that if,
if you're the type of person it starts getting into like threesomes and tying
each other up,
he started getting like really freaky.
It's way easy to go too far with that.
It's way like if you hear about someone like I'm just in a sax all day long,
just love sex.
Is it just sex or how long does it take for a ball gag comes out,
you know,
is it a month in your relationship?
You know,
like a year later,
what are you going to be into a year from now?
Just duct tape.
Did I like ripping it off of her and let you know there's people that get in,
like how does that happen?
They go down one of those pervy roads now you just got deep.
Yeah,
go down [inaudible] road and you just can't get satisfied.
It's like people have this weird thing of constantly want wanting progress.
If they,
if they have a house that's 4,000 square feet,
they want a house,
it's 5,000 square feet.
They make half a million dollars a year.
They want to make $1 million a year.
They always want to take things to the next level.
And that includes like freaky shit.
Well that's the American way.
You always want more,
more.
You want the bigger TV.
And even,
I'm definitely guilty of that.
You know,
I live in a really modest apartment that I love,
but the other day I was like,
you know,
I could probably go for a bigger apartment,
but why I live by myself,
my apartment's fine.
I don't need a bigger one.
Right.
Um,
when it comes to,
you know,
physical stuff,
I think you kind of just get desensitized by things.
You know,
there have been many studies about what porn does to the brain and you start off
by watching something that might be considered softcore and that's enough to,
you know,
do the job.
Um,
and then all of a sudden you're watching more and more hardcore stuff and you
just become desensitized to it.
And for a lot of teenage boys that grow up on that kind of stuff,
that's what they expect from women,
you know,
are girls,
once they start having sex,
it's really scary stuff.
And there it's changing people.
Sexuality without a doubt though,
the bushes gone.
The Bush died because of porn.
I heard that you're upset about that.
I'm terrified
they let porn when it doesn't make sense.
It's like everybody let porn when before nobody had a problem until like 1990.
Yeah.
Nobody had a problem with a hairy vagina.
It was just what it was.
I mean,
people trimmed around them,
but generally there was a lot going on down there,
especially if you dated an Italian girl,
what have you.
But now it's like their victory is just universal.
It's like the,
the victory over that aesthetic.
The victory over this shaved,
yeah.
Waxed the genitals.
Well,
those women are supposed to symbolize male desire.
They're supposed to symbolize what a man wants,
you know,
and then that has an influence on regular women and they think,
oh,
am I supposed to look that way?
Am I supposed to groom that way?
Um,
there have been stories of women that injure themselves because they'll go get
bleached and areas that they shouldn't be getting bleached.
And it's just amazing to me that it's that influential.
Okay.
I know.
It's very strange.
It's,
it's a silent,
influential thing.
It is.
It's very odd.
And I was when,
when the markets are crashing and government bailouts were going down,
um,
I was fascinated.
I was like,
how come nobody ever wanted to bail out the porn industry?
Like,
why would they pretend that the porn industry isn't this giant monster business
that all the sudden just evaporated?
Like half of it,
three quarters of it.
I don't know what the number of it that just disappeared.
Yeah.
Because of the Internet.
Right.
But so like,
who's pretending that this isn't a real business?
Like everyone's like flawless.
I guess still just have to exist on their own.
Meanwhile you're watching it like that person's a fan of it.
He probably has like a bunch of different videos that he has like bookmarked on
his laptop or something.
Right?
Yeah,
definitely.
But at the same time,
which politician would come out and say,
we need to bail out the porn industry.
That would be political suicide.
We live in this puritanical society.
I mean that would be insane.
There's also the same sort of feeling that happened with the music business is
that,
you know,
like the music business went out as well with the downloads of MP three s and
file sharing.
They lost a giant piece of revenue.
I mean just evaporated and no one really was considering bailing them out
either.
It's like it was like,
you know,
you kind of should have figured this out.
Dummies.
Yeah,
well I agree with you on that,
but at the same time,
everything always goes back to who is funding our politicians.
You know,
Wall Street,
these big bankers,
these are the people that fund the campaigns for our politicians,
which is why they just willy nilly went for the bailout.
Um,
and by the way,
after the bailout happened,
we did nothing to break up these too big to fail banks.
They still exist and they're still doing the same type of bullshit that'll lead
to another economic collapse.
I mean,
the regulation that we passed was nothing.
So it's just,
it always goes back to money in politics,
which know we talk about on the show all the time.
If someone is funding you,
whether it's the media or whether you're a politician,
you're not going to go against them.
You're always going to bail them out.
Yeah.
Turns,
we kind of described it as a,
he do.
How would you describe it?
He described it as a special interest.
Oligarchy disguising itself as a democracy.
Oh yeah.
We,
we have legalized bribery in this country.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
I mean,
when you really stop and think that that is,
it's gotten to the point that it is today where essentially it's open.
It's pretty obvious it's there.
They control virtually every single aspect of our economy,
our society.
It's all just money generating hubs.
These big giant spaceships filled with assholes that are just sucking money out
of a,
out of whatever,
whether it's through oil or natural gas or whatever they're doing.
Why do oil subsidies exist?
Like,
good question.
Why don't people ask the government that like,
why the hell are we giving these massive profitable oil companies?
Subsidies?
It's insane.
At the same time,
we're cutting funding for education.
We're privatizing public schools,
which is a complete and utter disaster
subsidy.
Sounds like they should get it.
It's like,
well,
there's this oil subsidies.
Okay.
Oil subsidies,
you know,
it's not like oil donations or oil payola if they'd call it oil payola who would
go,
wait a minute.
What is that?
Why do they get more?
I don't.
They have a lot of money.
Yeah.
What's happening here?
Profitable industry in the United States,
in the world.
You know,
so it's,
it's frustrating stuff,
but fortunately,
you know,
there are ways around it.
Citizens United was a terrible supreme court ruling,
which effectively allows corporations to act as people and make these unlimited
campaign donations to politicians.
So one way that you can get around that is by creating a constitutional
amendment,
which we're trying to do at the young Turks.
Um,
there's a political action committee that we formed called Wolf Pack.
I'm,
your audience can learn more about it at wolf dot dash [inaudible] dot com and
basically it would have state leaders,
um,
propose a resolution and the resolution would,
uh,
create a constitutional convention where you can make an amendment to the
constitution that would get money out of politics and that would fix so many
problems because then our broken democracy would change into a system that it
was intended to be.
Where our elected politicians are supposed to represent us,
the people instead of corporations.
Well,
when you back something in the corner and shine a light on it,
you really get to know its true nature.
Yeah.
And if that ever does come to play,
it would be a very fascinating moment to see how the system that's in place
today would deal with the idea of taking money out of politics and what kind of
a scramble would take place.
Yeah,
that would be,
it would be quite weird to say.
It would be.
It's,
I'm not gonna lie,
it's definitely going to be difficult to do.
I,
you know,
Janky Ugur is really optimistic about it.
I'm not as optimistic as he is,
but I think that if,
if the American people become a little more politically active and they signed
the petitions necessary and they hold their state representatives accountable,
I think that this could happen.
You know,
it just takes a little bit of political activism and unfortunately there's this
huge level of apathy right now,
um,
which I don't understand because the political climate is leading to this
economic meltdown and all of the problems that people are experiencing right
now.
Income inequality,
wealth inequality,
it's scary stuff.
I mean,
we lie to ourselves when we say that we live in the best country in the world.
We have legalized bribery.
We need to fix it.
We need to fix our democratic process.
When,
when you look at the future of this country,
the way it's running,
the way it is currently operated,
how long can that,
it seems like it's fallen apart at the wheels.
It seems like it's like this crazy thing that's spinning and shaking and sucking
money out and freaking out.
How long can this thing operate the way it is right now?
I'm not sure.
I mean,
that's a really good question,
but people are really starting to feel,
you know,
the,
the downfall of how our system is working.
Like just to give you an example,
this number of blows my mind.
Uh,
the top 10% in this country own 75% of the wealth.
That is bananas.
That's a lot of money and 10% ballers.
Everyone else is struggling.
They're struggling.
Um,
top 1% owns one third of the wealth in the country.
and so people are struggling to make ends meet.
And the reason why that's happening is because we're seeing these huge tax cuts
for the most wealthiest people.
You know,
why is it that we're supposed to have the highest corporate tax rate?
But when,
because of corporate loopholes,
we actually have the lowest corporate tax rate.
I mean we got to get rid of those loopholes and then you have the Republicans
saying,
yeah,
you know what,
we should raise taxes.
One way we can do that is by getting rid of deductions.
Which deduction do they want to go after?
Homeowners,
they want to go after people who get that uh,
interest rate deduction in their taxes.
And that of course impacts the middle class.
So it's just,
there's just a lot of frustrating stuff going on.
It seems like there's too much stuff going on for everybody to pay attention to
everything.
And that's one of the reasons where the apathy comes down.
It's just too freaky.
There's too much happening.
It's too nutty.
It's not going to get fixed.
Shit.
Close the shade.
I'm going to take a nap,
I'm going to watch the Kardashians or,
you know,
play video games or do whatever I need to do to distract myself.
And I don't blame people for doing that.
A lot of these issues are really complicated and complex.
You know,
you have to sit down and do so much research.
We have this mainstream media that's also broken.
They're not reporting the real news.
You know,
you have to really depend on independent media to get real facts.
And so I don't blame people for wanting to be distracted,
but at the same time,
if we allow things to continue the way they are,
we're going to have the wealthiest people living in their castles with motes
around them.
While we're going to struggle to find private security because everything that
is publicly funded is going to be defunded,
including our education.
We're seeing that happen now.
Nobody ever wants to think that the operating system that we have that runs our
society could fall apart.
Nobody ever wants to think that all of a sudden there'll be no cops cause they
don't get paid.
That's,
that's happened in places like Camden,
New Jersey.
Yep.
Perfect example.
Yeah.
Enough cops.
It's insane.
And of course,
I mean it's common sense.
Their crime rate shot up as a result of that.
Of course
it was a free ride.
Yup.
I mean that,
that's,
if you were like a really bad person,
does like the best place to move in the country.
Yup.
He'll be like,
look,
there's no cops then they don't even have them.
Yeah.
That's
mall little crumble
laying in the foundation of our society or just a little one and you know,
maybe they fixed it for now,
but eventually that could happen.
There was an Anthony Bordain special I was watching today.
His name.
Yeah,
he's great.
His new show for the CNN show,
he was in Detroit and uh,
he was just going over these factories where they used to make these amazing
cars and now they're just completely fallen apart and it's,
it's,
it's freaky.
It's freaky to see how this city of 2 million plus people now is like less than
700,000 and you could buy a house for like 500 bucks.
And he was like touring around the city and checking it out and I was that if
that can happen that quickly.
Yup.
That's just one city that can happen other places too.
I like this whole thing is like barely hey together with chewing gum.
And I think the most frustrating part about that is,
you know we have politicians that will pass policies that lead to the collapse
of certain cities.
California is in a lot of trouble right now because of a proposition we pass in
1978 called proposition 13 it capped property taxes at 1.2% and as a result we
started defunding our education,
which is why the La Usd went from being one of the best school districts in the
country to being one of the worst school districts in the country.
And we just lost out on a ton of revenue as a result of our low,
very low property taxes.
And so they'll pass policies like that.
In the case of California,
of course Californians voted for it,
which was disastrous.
But then at the same time they'll cut government programs that'll help the
poorest people,
whether it's the snap program or the food stamp program or you know,
the welfare programs,
wherever that help needy kids.
And it's like,
look,
if you don't want to spend this much money on governmental programs or social
programs,
then stop passing policies and tax cuts that make it really,
really difficult for people to make ends meet.
Well,
I think if it wasn't for shows like yours and people like you and chank who are
exposing this stuff and people in the new media,
people that are writing these very,
very popular blogs,
if it wasn't for that,
yeah,
this information wouldn't be going out and if the information wasn't going out,
people wouldn't realize what a cluster fuck it really is.
They would tune into the nightly news and get this sense that everything's going
to be okay.
Which is basically what America did until the Internet came around.
Yeah.
It seems like within the 10 15 plus years of the act of Internet,
the whole world is just stopped and went,
wait,
what the fuck are we doing?
Like everyone shaking their head,
looking left and right.
Confusion,
turmoil and questioning on a level that I don't think we've seen before.
And this weird new thing where anybody can just stick a camera and attach,
know a Usb it to a laptop and boom,
you're online.
I know.
Making youtube videos or making mp3s.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
It's a weird,
weird time.
Gets me really excited like just thinking about it because the possibilities are
endless.
And I mean,
we had the young Turks,
we had no marketing budget,
we had no publicity,
we had nothing.
All we did was create a business model that worked.
Uh,
Jank does the really serious political reporting,
which I'm jealous of.
That's what I want to do.
Um,
and then I come in and I do the stuff that goes viral online.
Why would she be
jealous of paying attention to this system?
I love politics.
I,
and don't get me wrong,
Marriott,
maybe I will know the,
I love I,
I mean I studied political science for my masters and it's just always been a
passion of mine since I was in high school.
So,
even though things are really bad right now,
I have this passion to try to make a difference.
And so I see Jank making a difference and I'm really proud of him and he's
someone that's been my mentor,
someone that I look up to.
And you know,
I want to be able to analyze politics as well as he does.
At the same time,
you know,
I was brought in for something completely different.
I was brought in to make the company money and that's basically what I do.
Um,
the stories that I cover in my hour of the show are sometimes very important
social stories.
Um,
you know,
whether it's gay rights,
women's rights,
whatever,
you know,
men's rights when it comes to how they get screwed over,
when it comes to children and marriage and basically the law,
men,
men are basically screwed over when it comes to sexual harassment and stuff.
But women aren't like,
it's amazing.
Um,
but that's a side note,
but then,
you know,
I'll do the stories that are really stupid,
but people love them.
Like we'll do a Miley Cyrus story and it'll get like millions of views and we'll
make a ton of money off that video,
but there's no value to that story.
So I always feel guilty doing it.
So I'll have,
I'll have days where I'm just like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a big failure.
This is what I do for my life and I feel guilty about it.
I hear what you're saying.
But at the same time,
following politics is like following some fucking fake minstrel show.
It's fake.
It's discouraging.
There's no question about it.
I always feel like I had this conversation with Jamie Kilstein wants from s dude
from citizen radio.
I knew what they were talking about,
politics and I go,
do you ever think that by following this fake horse and pony show that you're
like,
you like lending credence to it because you're an intelligent person and you're
pretending this isn't all just assholes who are getting bribed because that's
what it is.
Yeah.
It's really
just a bunch of assholes that are getting bribed and they're the ones and
they're cronyism and all this weird shit going on with laws and things they can
and can't get away with and what they can and can't get charged with.
Well,
I mean,
look,
there's,
there's a huge difference between political reporters in the mainstream that
just report on it,
but they don't really give a shit about making a difference.
And then there's a huge difference between people like Jamie and Allison on
citizen radio or the young Turks or any other,
uh,
what is it called?
Ah,
named just a lost me.
No,
not Alex Jones.
Alex Jones.
You guy's been stealing our thunder for coming at you.
A youtube views.
infowars.com the number one media source in the nation.
Young Turks tries to pretend they have similar ratings.
So you've seen that.
That's awesome.
Alex is a friend of mine.
Is He?
Yeah,
he's crazy.
He's mine.
It's mine.
I have no problem with a great guy though.
I love him.
If you met him,
he's a sweetheart.
Did meet him and he ended up liking him.
So I believe it.
I believe it.
Um,
but his response video to us was hilarious.
I'll so many different levels.
Like put a shirt on dude.
What a fucking shirt on.
Like if you're trying to make a decent point and you don't want to seem like
you're loony,
put a fucking shirt off
but don't.
If you're Allen's Joe's,
y'all,
y'all fucking shirt over 111 stations,
XM probably naked.
Most likely.
These websites,
more views.
No one's gonna care.
I'm number one.
Oh,
I love this video period.
Globally.
Even Rolling Stone,
New York magazine,
all the gun actuaries.
I'm number one.
He's number one period.
Yeah.
By the way,
he's,
here's one that he's missing.
It's a shirt
that later.
He's,
he's crazy.
I've known Alex Long
Time.
I did a DVD in 1999 and he and I put on a Bush masks.
I was a Bush junior and he was Bush senior and we put on these mask,
we ran around the,
uh,
Austin state capitol,
like the Front Yard and filmed it when Bush got elected.
The title of DVD was belly of the beast.
So I like,
it was right when Bush was getting elected.
We decided to do this in Austin and he,
him and me are in this,
uh,
this video and he's singing a song.
He sings this like crazy new world order song when he wrote,
Oh,
that's,
that's not us.
That's a different one.
The other one,
we were actually wearing these masks,
but uh,
I've known him for
forever.
He's a really good guy.
I don't,
I don't deny that.
I'm sure he is a good guy.
I don't tell me the truth.
Is he like playing a role when he's on camera because I don't believe that he's
really that crazy.
Like some of the stuff he says,
I just don't believe he believes I'm,
I do
not know.
I would not to know.
I think he's a very complex man.
I think there's a lot going on beneath the surface.
There's a lot of layers to that cake and I think that a lot of people look at
him and think he's a screaming maniac.
But he was right about a lot of shit.
A long time ago.
He was saying that the NSA is going to be reading all your emails and looking
through,
he said they're there,
they're going to make deals with major data networks with a t and t and Google.
He was saying this a long time ago.
Yeah.
And I specifically remember having conversations with a friend and him and my
friend was like,
that is so crazy.
Why would they do that?
They're not going to do that.
Do you?
Do you really think that the law would ever let them do that?
Hello?
Hello.
Hey,
all the law.
And he'll,
he'll get fucking crazy and he'll go,
Alex Jones.
Iyanya
but you know,
here's the thing,
that strategy or that delivery is effective.
Um,
because there have been people who have been reporting about,
you know,
civil liberties violations for a while and they get no attention.
So sometimes the squeaky wheel will get the attention and you know,
if,
if that's what he needs to do to get coverage of those important new stories,
it's totally fine.
The thing is,
you know,
there,
there are little sprinkles of truth to some of the stuff that he reports.
And then some of the stuff that he reports is just crazy and it's made up,
you know,
so it's like,
I don't know where to fall with that guy because I want to support them with
some stories.
But then other stories,
I'm like,
dude,
you need to tone it down.
Well,
I don't know what the process is for acquiring information,
vetting it out,
and then publishing it,
yelling at the youtube channel.
I don't know what it is,
what the process is,
but I know that he's right about a lot of things and I know that he's passionate
about a lot of things,
but I think that he probably needs a better filter.
Yeah.
You know,
I think there's a few rants.
He'll go on.
We'll,
you're like,
wait a minute.
Oh,
What the fuck are they doing?
Yeah.
Chem trails.
Do you understand how many planes were in the sky every night?
Brian Chem trails blocking out the sun.
I can't even fucking grow tomatoes here in Austin,
Texas.
No,
no,
no.
Your impression of him is amazing.
I've been hanging out with them more than a decade.
That's uncanny.
That's insane.
But he,
um,
he'll go off about something and then you'll go,
but did you know that this and that and that,
you know,
like you'll,
you'll have counters to those,
but if those don't get in there,
yeah.
Those don't get in there.
They get new world.
Order it out.
If they get black Holler,
copter it out.
Yeah.
Yes.
Ricochet off.
He wants to see a conspiracy in every fucking thing that's ever existed ever.
If you come up to him about whatever it is,
name at JFK,
the Iran Contra Whitewater death of Vince foster.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a million stories.
Worries.
They never end.
He'll just fucking come at you.
But he's been right about a lot of stuff that's really freaky.
Yeah.
One thing that he reported on that very few people caught was the use of paid
police officers to pretend to be people that are in a crowd protesting and then
agent provocateurs and they
would start smashing things.
Yeah.
He covered this.
And Seattle when the World Trade Organization was making there will believe it
was the 90s when they were,
there was these massive protests and the protests went violent while he,
he has all these photos of like the bottom of their boots,
military issue vibrams and he like points all this like these are police
officers,
they're wearing masks,
no one else is.
And they're the only ones doing any damage there,
smashing things and they're doing it.
So then the police can come in and start arresting peaceful people,
which they normally couldn't do.
And I thought that was the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life.
Okay.
The crazy thing is,
you know,
when it came to the occupy protestors,
they weren't even agent provocateurs.
They were just cops like breaking shit and starting the violence.
And you know,
they got a little bit of criticism for it,
but the media would pick up the story and make it seem as though the occupy
protesters were the violent ones.
They would do everything necessary to discredit them,
which made me so angry because finally in this country there was a little bit of
political activism.
They changed the conversation because we were talking about bullshit until
occupy came along and talked about wealth,
wealth,
inequality.
Um,
and then you know,
you have the mainstream that totally discredited them and then they just kind of
fizzled out.
And I had so much hope for that movement.
I really know what fuck that movement w them not being organized.
So with soap soap,
what didn't get enough?
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yes.
To many stinky motherfuckers out there and drum circles I cover is a big part of
it.
I caught,
I covered occupy La and occupy Oakland.
Occupy Oakland was a scary situation to cover because there they were a lot more
militant.
Their,
I mean their intentions were in the right place,
but their delivery was a little scary.
So I just kind of felt like shit could hit the fan.
Yeah.
Like one wrong move and violence could break out.
Uh,
but,
but they,
they,
it was because they were overly protective.
They knew what was happening to other protesters.
You know,
look at what happened at Uc Davis.
I think,
you know what,
that cop spraying that pepper spray on those students that are just sitting
there.
Um,
so I think that they were just overly protective as they should have been
because of the treatment that all these protesters were dealing with
and the treatment throughout history.
I mean all they have to do is go back and to look at what was going on during
the Vietnam War.
Look at what happened at Kent State when they start shooting.
Then the arm,
the national guard is shooting at the students that were protesting.
I mean that,
that's not that long ago people were aware of that kind of stuff.
But when I saw this Alex Jones thing,
I really thought it was the dumbest thing I'd ever seen.
I was like,
this is no way that could ever be possible.
There's no way.
Co and then he presents it like very clearly,
very cleanly over and over again,
all the different news stories that pointed to different various incidents that
took place,
including them.
So request they,
they got all of the agent provocateurs in a house,
the cops negotiated with them and then let them go.
I mean the whole thing goes like so cut and dry and clear.
When you have evidence backing up,
you know,
your belief that something is a conspiracy.
Then of course,
I mean you have strong evidence and all believe it.
Um,
but it's one thing to have the evidence.
It's another thing to purport that something is going on and then not having the
evidence to that.
I think he needs a filter.
I think he's got a lot of his heart and his intentions are in the right place
and the dude will go to war.
Like you'll fucking took it out in the street with somebody.
He's fucking crazy.
I'm aware.
Yeah,
he's a madman,
but he's also a good guy.
Like I,
I just think that he needs a filter.
Yeah.
But he's right.
More than he's wrong.
I'll tell you that.
Especially now.
This is,
uh,
Alex and me and uh,
that's,
that's Alex on the left and me on the right.
And this is his song.
Oh my God,
this,
that's Alex singing.
That's,
that's great.
That's my buddy.
He's up there.
He is.
And just sounds like a fun person to hang out with.
Yeah.
He's very fun to hang out with.
He's great to drink beers with.
Yeah,
I can imagine a good dude.
He's funny.
He says a lot of really funny shit.
He's,
he's a good guy too.
He's a sweetheart.
He really is.
So did he ever talk to you about why he got on us about like views?
Oh,
I don't ask him any questions about things like that.
He's been in some disputes with friends of mine and he's been disputes welcomes
girl.
Just go.
It's just Alex man.
You got to have to deal with that on your own.
That is really funny.
Yeah.
But he's,
like I say,
he's a good guy.
He's just,
he wants a better America.
He really does.
He's not in a greedy guy.
He's not a guy who's in it for the money.
Are you the shirt off his back clearly aren't using stamps.com.
He,
uh,
he really is like the real deal.
Like,
he really wants a better America.
He really wants to get out all the corruption,
the scum.
But he believes that the global elites are trying to live to be a thousand years
old.
What they're doing right now with stem cells,
the reason why the Bush administration and they'll just like,
how did you meet him?
How did that happen?
Uh,
I met him,
uh,
in Texas through a friend of mine who's friends with him.
I knew him from his radio day.
Well he still has a radio show,
but now it's more Internet based.
But he had a radio show.
I think his radio show is still pretty popular though.
And like those dudes that have those fucking,
those a ham radios.
Yeah.
Tune in tune in the Alex Jones,
the fucking just thinking that that's this is that thinking that,
you know,
the only problem with that is just that thinking that goes along with that,
which is like collect gold,
like dig a hole in the ground for a nuclear shelter.
They're like preppers and people start putting battering rams and their pickup
trucks lazy.
I don't think that's the way to do it.
I don't want to live my life like that where you're constantly paranoid and
you're worried about dooms day there.
Look,
there's some really scary shit happening in the government right now.
I will not take take away from that,
but I don't believe in the doomsday prepper is like they need to calm down their
paranoia.
Paranoia's misplaced
unless something happens like what happened two days ago in the Philippines.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the real issue.
Yeah.
Mother Nature.
Mother Nature is the issue and we keep fucking with her.
So allegedly allegedly that because you know,
not enough scientists agree on,
you know,
excuse me.
There's plenty of scientists that disagree.
They also all happen to be working for oil companies,
gas companies.
They'll call the brothers.
The Koch Brothers will fund scientists to put out studies that claim that either
climate change does not exist.
It.
This is just a normal trend that we were experiencing with our planet or that it
exists,
but it's not,
you know,
created by humans way back to the 1950s they were doing that with cigarettes
when when people were trying to come out saying,
hey,
I think these things are giving us cancer.
Yeah,
we fucking funded a shitload of studies and we're like,
no,
look,
it's absolutely good for you.
Yeah.
You can find certain things.
We were talking about it on the podcast yesterday worth nicotine actually can be
a medicine in certain circumstances help people with heart issues and ADHD
issues and all these different things.
So like you could find a way to rationalize if you were a real piece of shit
that like you should probably smoke cigarettes.
You won't get Adhd.
Yeah.
Another example of money influencing the behavior of Americans and the
information that gets put out there.
Yeah.
When we were talking earlier about being addicted to items and being addicted to
things and how you wanted to get a bigger apartment,
even though you don't need it.
I'm guilty as charged too,
but I think about it all the time and what I'm starting to believe is that human
beings like the reason why we like to think of ourselves as being something that
we're in much more in control of then the just the woes of nature.
But I kinda think that more likely than that everything is natural.
And even though we break down like ant behavior is being natural and wolf
behavior is being natural,
but humans,
well,
you know,
we have freewill and we have education.
We have maybe,
but when I look at like the trend,
like where it is right now,
it's,
I don't know how it got here,
but let's pretend it's all nature.
What is it doing?
But what it's doing is it's making things.
It's making crazier and crazier things everyday.
The whole race is working together.
And one of the ways it ensures that people consistently technologically innovate
is by making it attractive to have the newest,
latest shit.
And everybody wants it.
And like,
Ooh,
that new Lexus,
look at that commercial.
Oh my God,
I got a habit and it's a fucking new laptop and it's a new phone and it's a new
ear piece.
I mean it's also,
it's also a status thing.
It's a status symbol to have the latest and greatest.
No doubt.
We recently covered this story about Barneys.
I don't know if you've talked about it at all and you're a show,
but there was this young black man who went into a Barney's.
He purchased a $350 belt with a debit card and allegedly the cashier called the
authorities on him because she didn't believe that a black guy can afford this
$350 belt.
So the cops came,
they started questioning him.
They said,
we know we need proof indicating that that's your debit card.
He had to call chase and prove like,
yes,
that is his debit card,
you know,
they like detained them for a little while.
And then finally they let him go.
So he's suing Barneys now for racial profiling.
So we'll see how that case plays out.
But you know,
aside from the racial profiling component of that story,
I was just shocked that I think he's 19 that a 19 year old would save up
multiple paychecks by the way to Po to buy a $350 belt.
And it's like,
it goes against everything.
I believe.
I hate that kind of materialism and I'm not,
he's a victim here,
so I'm not trying to criticize him.
It's more of a societal thing where we all want to show off our new shiny
handbag and it's fucking bullshit.
I hate when women fall for that crap when they work multiple months just to
afford like a $2,500 handbag.
And it's like,
who are you trying to prove?
Like what are you trying to prove and who you're trying to prove it to?
You're trying to show off to other women,
right?
Which by the way,
if you're like a real woman,
I think that you shouldn't get jealous by that kind of crap.
You know?
And real woman.
Well,
you said it like a real man
masculine,
like,
no,
I have this.
As I get older,
I mean I'm,
I'm getting obsessed with a person's character and I'm,
I'm,
I care less and less about the bullshit.
That doesn't matter.
So when I was younger,
you know,
I got brainwashed into thinking,
Hey,
you know what?
You need to make sure that you marry a guy who's like really established in his
career because you want to make sure you can take care of you.
Fuck that.
I want to take care of myself.
Like I don't need a guy to take care of me.
And that's not to say that I,
I don't want a man in my life.
I definitely do.
I want a partner in my life and I want it to be like a real partnership where we
help each other out.
But at the same time,
like this obsession with materialism makes me sick to my stomach.
It's distracting.
And it makes people feel that if they can't afford certain things,
then they're not good enough,
that they're not worthy.
If they don't have the money to shop at Barney's,
then they're less than,
well,
I definitely think you're right.
From a sociological last part,
uh,
aspect.
I feel like the,
the,
the whole desire is,
is fruitless and silly and weird and it exists more it with people that can't
have it and want it very badly,
but there's a lot of people that are rich that just go shopping every day,
but it's just the whole never gets filled.
Yeah.
It's always,
it's never like the big rush that you get.
At least if you're poor and you buy a $2,000 watch,
like Holy Shit,
and you look at it,
I can't believe I got it.
Woo.
Well,
if you're really wealthy,
if you're some billionaire character,
nothing,
nothing.
It doesn't even register.
It's like this doll thumping on your helmet because it never really gets to
skin.
I just,
I don't like making people feel like they're worthless because they can't afford
for them.
They mean who makes them feel like that?
Is it a,
isn't it on them and it,
sure.
I mean,
look at,
listen to pop culture,
listen to all the rap songs and all that.
Oh,
you know,
I got my new,
or whatever.
I don't think they brag about that car.
Don't get me wrong,
whatever,
whatever.
I got my Mayback right,
right.
They rap about that shit.
Who cares about your may back?
You know,
like,
I don't know why people are so obsessed with that.
And then these young kids think,
oh my God,
I got to work really hard for that may back.
Which is why so many people get involved in the financial sector and they sell
their souls because they just want to be rich.
And we need people who want to be teachers.
You know,
I'll be at,
most of them get screwed over with really,
really crappy salaries and we should definitely pay our teachers better.
But people don't gravitate toward jobs that actually helped the community
because they're so obsessed with making money.
And I hate seeing our brightest students go toward the financial sector instead
of,
you know,
focusing on jobs that do help the community,
whether it's,
you know,
in,
in fields that lead to technological innovation or to medical innovation.
And of course doctors make a lot of money,
but you know,
a lot of scientists that do some serious research that really benefits society
don't make a lot of money.
It's true.
And so I,
I just hate the incentive structure that we have these days and this emphasis on
always having the,
the newest,
most expensive item available.
It's definitely ridiculous.
But as a person trying make an attempt to look at it objectively,
if I was like an alien species to coming down to observe earth,
I would say they're in a mad scramble to create the next technological marvel.
They're in a mad scramble to create the,
the new Internet,
the next thing.
And they're going to go from that to the next thing.
They're transforming themselves.
They're essentially,
it's a longterm cocoon that turns a caterpillar into a butterfly.
It's just taking a few hundred years.
But technologically there's some sort of a symbiotic relationship that we have
with,
with technology and that's fueled by materialism,
materialism,
drive.
It ensures that people consistently by the newest things innovate and constantly
trying to impress with the latest.
Yeah.
I just sociologically,
I agree with you 100%.
Yeah.
But I think that there's,
there's probably something more going on yeah.
And we're just not aware of because we're like trapped in the middle of the
hurricane of it all.
Yeah.
I think you make a really good point about,
you know,
uh,
gadgets and technology.
I guess what I'm more focused on is just like the designer bullshit that people
buy into.
That kind of stuff
frustrates me.
I just think it's a side shoot of the same issue.
The money thing too.
I think about that,
like this desire to pursue massive amounts of money and chain.
What does that all really doing?
I mean,
if it's all just a pool of money and everybody's trying to,
you know,
keep it moving and keep it active,
what does it really do?
Well,
it buys things and if it's buying thing,
someone's making things,
someone's making things are going to keep improving those things because
everybody wants the newest thing.
Yeah.
It's basically the same engine,
this innovation engine that's like pushing forward and we're all trapped up in
it in like as calling it culture and calling it all these other different
things.
But what it really is,
is a,
a mad scramble to make new technology.
So
what's your,
what's your guilty pleasure?
Like what do you like to splurge on even though you might feel that might be
really,
yeah,
it does.
I could expensive.
Yeah.
They get expensive.
Well,
I,
I'm,
there's an art form to making pool cues,
believe it or not.
And um,
I play a lot of pool and uh,
I used to play,
I was obsessed.
I used to play eight,
10 hours a day when I lived in New York.
I was,
it was,
yeah.
When my manager was telling me that it was a,
it was affecting my career.
It was because I was paying more attention to playing pool than I was to comedy.
Yeah.
It was,
I was completely obsessed.
Um,
but there's not that many pool cue manufacturers,
makers,
the but the artisans,
the real handmade ones.
Like there's a,
a guy named Sam Bodie berries and Bodie,
he's like world famous.
His Dad was Gus,
Sam bodies' was one of the original pool cue makers.
Like that name has like a lot of weight to it and these cues or like this
artistic functional art that you could play pool with,
but they're also like really beautiful.
I'm fascinated by them.
My friend created,
my friend Eric has a company called sugar tree and he makes these beautiful cues
all based on woods that are like really exotic and strange Berles and,
and weird like figure in the wood and he's obsessed with wood.
And because like you get like you,
you,
when you buy,
when it was Qsi you play with it,
you could literally see the passion that it took that this guy made this guy who
is obsessed with wood,
you know,
he's really obsessed with different grains and tonal qualities and aging them.
And it's this real artistic expression and it just,
it's a functional piece of art.
I'm obsessed with them.
Yeah.
I mean there's nothing wrong with that.
That's very like obscure.
Like I like,
I've never heard anyone talk about pool cues.
Yeah.
That's my guy.
Have a big cabinet fill of them.
That's my guilty pleasure.
Nice.
Yeah.
I just love to play pool.
Nice.
It's a stupid thing to do.
I mean,
it doesn't matter whether the ball goes in the hole,
but it does matter.
Everything matters
if that's what you find pleasurable and you know,
it helps you blow off steam or whatever,
go for it.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I think there's a,
a microcosm to life in it.
I think there's a thing about pulling,
see these are,
these are,
uh,
handcrafted pool cues.
So how much do these cost?
Am I allowed to ask?
Yeah.
They,
some of them can cost several thousand dollars.
Wow.
Those ones you're looking at,
those are probably two or 3000 at least.
That's really pretty.
Yeah.
And they get real intricate and there's different ways they splice them
together.
Like you see those things at the end.
Like those are those little things inside of them are little inlays and as you
get further out,
those are different pieces of wood are spliced it together,
cut Kutney glued in place and then spun on a lathe and there,
you know,
exotic woods like that's ebony and he could see all these different uh,
in lace.
Some of them were probably made out of ivory and silver and all these terms they
used to,
you used to be legal to buy ivory to a,
to make pool cues with and he used to make the balls out of ivory and then
people realize what a piece of shit you have to be to kill an elephant.
So they cut that off,
but there's so much left over.
It's really kind of sad.
There's so much leftover from when they were just slaughtering elephants before
they started regulating it that you can get,
I've read and make in lays and stuff and pool cues.
It's everywhere.
So it becomes like a real issue,
like a moral issue.
You have to think like,
wow,
is that kind of fucked up?
But then it's like,
well,
what do you,
what are they going to do with the,
the animals like been dead since 1970 and they have these tusks,
he just going to let them go to waste or is it better to like put them in a
museum where people can look at them like it's a,
it's kind of an interesting moral dilemma,
but my friend Eric uses,
he uses this fossilized mastodon bone that he got.
He uses like 10,000 year old fossilized Walrus ivory that uh,
came from,
you know,
like they,
they just discovered get his hands on that.
That's insane.
Sisters and archaeologist.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
I think it's a sister.
Um,
but yeah,
he's,
he's like really into the,
I mean he doesn't use like that many,
he doesn't use like that money in lays.
His is all just about the wood,
like the quality of the wood.
I like that.
That's really interesting.
I never,
I would've never guessed that they could get that expensive.
The,
they get really expensive though.
Old Ones.
There's a man named ballot,
Bush [inaudible] who lived in,
you know like then he the 1960 [inaudible] and 1970s I think he made cues and in
the movie the color of money,
Paul Newman gave Tom Cruise a ballot,
Bush guy.
And just by saying that name that those cues started being worth 25 $30,000
because there's a finite number of,
and there's a fact,
it's probably like the queue that has the most forgeries is like Sam Bodie and
ballot Bush car,
the two,
a lot of fakes.
Why people like,
you know,
they'll just knock it off and pretend it's one of them cause you could sell it
for 25,000 bucks.
You're,
I'm guilty pleasure as much better than mine.
My nerves just food,
food like I don't,
I can't really think of,
I'm an object that I like to spend a lot of money on.
I just like to spend a lot of money on like a good experience.
Like,
if I'm going to travel or if I'm going to eat at a nice restaurant,
I'm going to go all out,
you know,
and not feel bad about it.
Um,
but that's pretty much it.
That just sounds like life.
I know I have a guilty pleasure.
I know.
I guess I'm trying to think.
I'm,
I'm a huge bargain shopper.
I don't really buy anything at full price.
I'm not really into that.
Well,
you should have said this.
Interesting.
I,
um,
is this because of the way,
like your responsibility that you feel for looking at the world and seeing how
fucked up things are that you feel bad spending a couple hundred bucks on a nice
meal?
Is that like what it is that it becomes a guilty pleasure because you're like,
fuck it,
I'm just going to do it
normally?
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe.
I think that there's something subconsciously that makes me feel guilty about
it,
but I can't really put my finger on it.
I think it's because I know how hard I work and you know,
seeing all that money go toward one experience or one meal makes me feel a
little bad.
But I actually would,
I like to do is if I'm going to go out and I'm going to spend some serious
money,
I make sure that I take people with me.
I spend the money on
them as well because then I feel like I'm doing something good for my friends.
And I read this study about how I'm,
the happiest people will actually spend money on others.
And it's totally true.
You feel really good when you take care of other people.
Um,
so,
you know,
I usually do that.
That's,
that's not my guilty pleasure.
That's the one thing that I will splurge on and I won't feel guilty about it.
I'll feel really good about it.
And then I hope,
you know,
one day when,
when my friends are in the mood,
like they'll take me out and they'll do the same thing.
One day you're waiting,
right?
I mean,
my friends,
I love my friends.
I,
I'm in a really,
as someone in my age group,
I'm in a really great place financially because I lived at home for a long time.
I saved money.
I was with someone that I was going to buy a house with.
Um,
that didn't work out.
So now I just have money that I'm not going to put toward a house and I can do
other things with it.
So I like to treat my friends to things once a,
you don't have to justify it.
Yeah.
But it seems like the a part of you because you're such a conscious and aware
person realizes that you are in this rare circumstance.
Yeah.
So it feels like a guilty pleasure,
I feel.
I don't know if it's guilt,
but I feel bad about a lot of things because no,
I don't have,
I have white guilt is something I don't have,
especially because,
and by the way,
I love that accusation that we get from our audience time to time,
all the fucking time.
And it's so funny because like I'm Armenian,
like both my,
both my parents came from Armenia,
so they,
they didn't have,
like my ancestors didn't have slaves.
Like they,
they try and tell him,
you're not white.
I'm white,
but I'm not like I'm not American.
I am American.
Okay.
This is not sounding good.
But like to say to say that I have white guilt would imply that I have ancestry
that did hideous things to black people,
which is why I now want to raise awareness about issues of racism.
Um,
and that's not true.
I want to raise awareness about that is because I want genuine equality.
You know,
you see cases where racial profiling does exist,
no doubt.
And you want to,
you want to raise awareness about that because you want society to progress.
You don't want to pretend as though these societal ills don't exist.
They do exist.
But at the same time,
you don't want to demonize people either.
You don't want to make blanket statements about all white people.
That's insane.
Yeah,
I've heard some pretty ridiculous blanket statements.
Um,
but what's,
what's really important is that the,
the,
the idea of racism should be eventually it should,
it shouldn't exist anymore.
One day the,
it should come a time where that has been ironed out of the human culture.
We've,
we've beaten it down.
It seems like if you go back to a few thousand years ago when they were burning
people at the stake for various beliefs,
we've managed to get past that.
We've managed to get past killing neighbors.
You know,
the rival countries that were like a block away from each other in Europe.
We managed to get past all that.
I wonder if one day we're going to get to a point where we don't give a fuck
what anybody is racist.
I wonder if there's gonna be some economic evenness where it'll eventually all
smooth out,
where it won't matter.
I wonder the same thing.
I'm not as optimistic about it though,
to be honest.
I'm pretty optimistic.
You are.
Yeah.
I didn't use to be,
but as time's gone on,
um,
uh,
the Internet is what makes me optimistic when I see like justice and,
and the voice of the Internet,
it's,
it seems to be a very ethical,
moral voice.
What do you think about,
you know,
some of the vigilante justice that you see online?
Like in the case of this,
uh,
the Steubenville rape case and how anonymous,
you know,
kind of rallied behind that victim.
I thought that was really inspiring even.
Yeah,
it's huge that,
that,
that stuff has to happen.
That's,
it has to happen.
You can't let people do that because that could be your daughter.
That could be your friend,
that could be your mom,
that could be anybody.
You can't let that happen and they can't let that fucking happen either.
That the fact that they let that happen,
you've got to clean that whole place out.
That's a disaster,
right?
Anybody who's involved in that,
what did you do?
What the fuck did you do?
You,
you just opened the door for this kind of shit to be swept under the rug by
future generations who find out about this as well.
This is like when,
when there's a gross injustice and it's,
and it doesn't get rectified,
there's,
there's this weird thing that happens where can spawn more gross injustice.
Yeah.
I mean it sets a precedent and if one person can get away with doing that type
of,
you know,
act or behaving in a certain way,
then other people will think like,
well I can do that.
I can get away with that.
And you know,
in the case of the Steubenville rape case,
I w I was actually really shocked at how many people bullied the girl after she
was raped.
And you see more and more stories like that popping up all over the place.
Right.
Think it's a human nature issue with a lot of young kids that have not been,
not only not have not been raised correctly,
but I think there's a lot of people that are just learning their kids,
raising themselves and then not even having conversations with them and they're
growing up with like animal instincts and the animal instincts are the go after
injured animals.
There's a weird thing.
It's scary,
terrifying thing,
especially when the injured animal is claiming that the Alpha,
the Social Alphas have,
have done this thing to them.
You know,
and then the Social Alphas is saying they didn't do it.
And then there's this weird sort of,
uh,
an appeasement thing going on where people are trying to gain the favor of the
Alphas by shitting on the victim.
It's terrifying stuff.
It's the worst aspects of humankind is this weird thing that we can have when we
gang up,
you know,
and,
and the parents of the victim,
I give them all the credit in the world because I'm going to be completely
honest.
If I were in that position,
I don't know if I would be able to prevent myself from doing something that
would,
that would lead me to getting prosecuted and thrown in jail.
Yeah.
It's um,
something happens to men.
The,
the get together and have a bunch of idiot men get together.
They think that that that's something that they can do.
And it's a,
and in the case of Steubenville,
they're boys,
they're teenagers and they think they can get away with it.
Well,
it's just men period.
I mean,
young men,
old men,
there's a,
there's,
there's a man thing that can happen if there's too many dummies and they get
together and they start thinking that they,
they're making sense or that they could,
she just focus full could do this.
And that's where like gang murders take place and gang beatings and you know,
I'm,
I'm sure there's a similar sort of group mentality that happens with women,
but it doesn't seem to turn into as much of a victimization thing.
It can happen.
I've heard of like groups of women beating up other women.
I've heard outside of that,
you know,
if a girl like fuck some girl's husband or something like that and she got her
friends and they all beat the shit out of the girl.
I've heard of that kind of stuff happening.
She's scary,
scary stuff.
I've heard of stories of women raping men,
Blah.
Terrible.
Um,
you were talking about this on the podcast yesterday.
The problem with male rights organizations.
Oh,
you guys must have gotten some serious hate for that.
No,
no,
because my point is always that,
yeah,
I mean there's a lot of dudes get fucked over and it comes to divorce laws.
A lot of the problem is when male rights advocates get disingenuous.
Like they were talking about rape issues.
There were saying the number one group that gets raped in this country is men in
prison.
The problem with that is of course that men are raping those men.
It's just,
it's more proof that men are cunts.
Men are raping men.
It's,
this is a stupid argument.
It doesn't,
that's the worst thing you should ever say.
You know,
you're just saying that we're just rapers,
we're just,
we rape each other.
We don't give a fuck.
Well,
rape anybody.
And that doesn't mean that men are victims.
Men are victims from men.
How does that support the,
the point that that's the real issue.
That's a really good point.
It's a dumb point.
Did they,
it's a disingenuous thing that they're saying.
Yeah.
Like guys aren't really wondering around life worried about getting raped.
They worry about it if they get imprisoned.
I just worry that,
you know,
the men's rights movement is a response to like radical feminism.
And I have a lot of issues with radical feminism because when you pretend as
though women are always the ones that get screwed over and men don't deal with
certain double standards and certain issues,
then you're being disingenuous.
You know,
you're doing a disservice to your own movement.
I mean,
there are some serious issues with,
um,
the way women are perceived in media.
For instance.
You know,
the way I'm perceived in the media is very different from how Jank is perceived
in the media.
Very different from how you're perceived in the media.
You know,
the comments that you will get usually.
Um,
we'll question the legitimacy or accuracy of something that you've said.
The Commons that I get don't necessarily criticize the legitimacy of what I'm
saying.
Of course I get comments like that as well.
But how often do you get comments about like,
oh,
you know,
I w I want Anna to sit on my face or I want Joe to sit on my face.
Like,
oh,
all the time.
Oh,
I stand corrected.
Then
some gay bear wants me to stick it in their mouth or something.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
That was happening,
you know?
But as
much as I'm sure I remember,
wouldn't even pretend.
I think that it's much more courageous.
I don't want to sound like I'm kissing your ass,
but it's much more courageous for a woman to do what you do than a man
to do what you do.
For a man to do what you do.
It's like men with opinions or like is common as like birds at Shit on cars.
Yes,
they're everywhere.
This is Matt.
Every,
every way.
You look at man as an opinion,
but women with an opinion that go public and like have this like very strong
stance.
They take on things.
Yeah.
And expect to be taken seriously.
It's like female standup comedians because female standup comedians there was so
limited in topics cause men don't want to hear you talk about politics.
Men Don't want it to hear women talk about certain things,
you know,
like anything where you're telling people how to live their lives.
But I don't want to hear that from women.
It's just a giant group of men just shut you off much harder.
I think that,
you know,
younger generations are becoming way more open to that.
Like we have a really young audience and for the most part I think that they're
open to me talking about politics.
Um,
like I said,
I don't get to do that as often as I would like on the show because that's not
my role on the show.
But there is,
um,
a huge chunk of our audience that's very open minded toward that.
However,
there's also a chunk of the audience,
and I'm just going based on what I've read on Youtube.
So there's a huge silence,
silent part of our audience,
and I'd never get to hear from.
Um,
but there is also a portion that just immediately sees me and thinks,
oh,
she's a young,
um,
whatever.
Relatively good looking.
And so they immediately see a correlation there with more chronic behavior.
Like,
oh,
she's attractive.
She must be.
Yeah.
Well you had a free ride.
That's what they think.
Oh yeah.
Golden ticket.
You're pretty,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
um,
I'll get comments,
you know,
asking,
what kind of sexual favors I gave my male colleagues to get to the position that
I'm in,
how rude.
And it's,
and it's so degrading because obviously none of that has ever happened,
but it's to be little,
the hard work that I've put into my career really,
really grind.
Okay.
But what you're doing right now is you're feeding the trolls.
I'm feeding the fucking shit out of the trolls.
I know they loved it
because he brought in,
it's all the comments of you having sex with your boss in order to get your job.
Yeah.
Everything you said it all.
And how offended you were of that.
And then when it's raining control bell.
I know,
but to be,
to be absolutely honest,
I completely stopped reading comments so they can go ahead and write them as
much as they want.
I'm not going to read that.
Just fucked up right there sister.
You just open up the door,
the gates of hell do your thing.
We'll know your tone
and girls.
Everyone be kind.
Yeah.
There's a real problem with writing things down online and not having any social
cues.
And I like looking at you and say,
you know,
and uh,
um,
I watched your thing on science and you know,
I just want you to know that your grasp of physics is a bit off and write this.
And you'd go,
Oh,
I'm,
you know,
I don't know shit about science.
And then you'd laugh.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
We both laughed together and that would be it be well that same guy and youtube,
there's fucking dumb bitch doesn't know shit about science because he is an in
front of you.
He's not talking to you again as a human,
it goes back to the whole anonymity.
The thing
that I actually worry about the most isn't even,
you know how my feelings are going to get hurt because who cares?
Like I'm,
I'm a public figure.
I need to have thicker skin and it shouldn't bother me.
I worry about like if I,
if I meet someone I'm interested in and I'm dating him and then all of a sudden
he decides,
first of all,
if I meet someone I'm interested in and I tell him what I do,
he's going to Google me.
Like that's the world we live in at this point,
right?
He's going to Google me and he's going to read the like the hideous shit that
people say about me and then is that going to influence his opinion of me?
Like I worry about that kind of stuff more than,
that's hilarious.
Do you really?
I do.
I mean there are,
I mean
that would be the last thing that I would worry about.
That's the very last thing that I would worry about is meeting someone and
having them be an influence by a Google search.
That's literally the last thing.
I've been on the show since I was 20 and you want to know how many stupid things
I've said on that show since I was 20 many.
Yeah.
Well that's normal.
It is.
It is normal.
Anybody that pretends it's not like you,
again,
you're just weeding out assholes.
I that anybody that pretends it's not normal to say something stupid when you're
20 and you're on a show that permanently records it.
My God,
if I ever got permanently recorded when I was 20 Oh,
in jail for hate crimes,
just for my words,
retarded person.
When I was 20 I was two.
I think most people are fools when they're 20 of course,
you're basically a child.
Definitely.
You know?
There's no way that you should be held accountable,
responsible.
Anybody should ever stick it in your face.
Things that you did when you're much younger.
Yeah,
I agree.
I agree,
but it'll happen,
I'm sure will weed out a dummy that you want in your life anyway.
You're right.
That's a good way of looking at it.
The best way of looking at it.
You know who you are.
If that guy can't figure that out,
fuck them.
Yeah.
Look at me.
I'm like the new Oprah for women already.
The Oprah from men
giving out advice,
teaching people how to fuck the relationships up oily.
Oh God.
Do what you gotta do.
Yeah.
It's gotta be hard being a check,
trying to,
trying to meet a dude out there in the wonderful world of uh,
uh,
and also being like a public figure.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
It is.
Um,
but whatever,
I think you're right.
You know,
you do weed out the assholes and you just,
you can't take yourself too seriously
cause you can't date a regular dude either.
You got a real problem.
What do you mean you're a little on the smart side?
It's a little on the little on the kids.
A little on the articulate side.
That's a little intimidating for guys.
And we're like,
you know what,
I'm not going to get shut down by this one.
I'm just going to pass.
I'm not even gonna try.
Do you get a lot of that where guys are going to try?
No.
Hmm.
I think a lot of dudes probably go,
you know what,
this is never going to happen for really,
and then they just stopped talking to you as soon as we get intimidated.
But that's good too.
Right?
Then you weed out pussies.
Does it suck?
No,
I don't.
I don't want those posties I just,
I don't want those pussies to exist.
Like you have nothing to be shy or intimidated
about,
like whatever.
Every,
every person can teach you something new.
Right.
But I will assume that you date,
yeah,
they can teach you how you can get stock now.
No,
but I will say that,
um,
when you said you can't date a regular person,
I thought like you have to date another public figure out,
which I'm not interested.
No,
no.
I'm a bad motherfucker.
You got a date?
Some dude who's really smart.
Definitely.
I'm definitely turned on by too much work intelligence,
too much work
that's just so rude thing.
Super laid back and you know,
low maintenance.
I actually am,
I'm not that bad.
I wouldn't think you were high maintenance,
but I would think that a woman who's a public,
you know,
and all Bolton,
all seriousness.
Yeah.
I would think that a woman who's a public figure,
a woman who is very articulate and intelligent and,
and it makes a living off of her opinions.
That's intimidated for a lot of dudes.
[inaudible] especially people that are not good at expressing themselves like
the,
what is the big thing with relationships?
It's the weird sort of,
uh,
expression dance that you do with each other.
Yeah.
You know,
how does,
how does she express when she's angry?
How do you express when you're angry?
Who does it kindly?
Who Does it?
Who's passive aggressive?
Yeah.
Who's intelligent when it comes to arguments.
Doesn't want to have an argument with you.
That's fucking rough action.
You argue on the Internet.
I haven't had an argument with a guy in a while.
Exactly.
The scared bunch of bitches.
No scared to say that.
I haven't put myself out there that much to be honest with you.
So I don't have too much experience with that.
Um,
I was in a really long term relationship and then now if just started dating,
um,
that's where the seventies music comes in.
No,
I started dating and then the dude at home,
here's this.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Trust me crying.
No,
he's not.
Yes he is.
No,
he's,
he's a good guy on the inside.
Trust me.
They all do.
Me included.
We all clock on the inside [inaudible] phone.
I'm done with this.
Ooh.
The
funny thing is I'm 100% certain he was going to listen to that.
We're just fucking around man.
I know.
But I will say like,
I,
I live in like the gayest area of Los Angeles,
which means it's like impossible to meet guys near me.
Um,
and,
and you're right.
Like I,
I don't know what,
two weeks I love that we're playing for and music right now,
Jamie.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm just having fun,
but I'm not a problem in your neighborhood meeting guys.
Yeah.
Well,
I live in a gay neighborhoods.
So many guys who pretend to not gay.
I'm like trying to pick up chicks.
Yes I have.
But meanwhile they're really gay and they just don't want to grab it.
Okay.
So my best friend and I talk about this all the time,
um,
I've been on a few dates with guys that I'm 100% certain are gay.
Um,
and,
and it's like,
why?
Why are you trying to ruin my life right now?
Like what do you think is going to happen?
Like you think I'm not going to figure it out and I'm going to end up like
dating you longterm and then you're going to destroy life.
No,
you're gay.
I can totally tell how can you sell?
You can just tell by the things and I'm not,
look,
I'm not trying to push stereotypes,
but when you're with a straight guy,
you just know like there's certain body language that indicates or implies that
he's like aroused or he's into you.
You know what I mean?
Like physically into you when you're like,
if I was a Douche bag guy.
So the way that the Douche bag guy translation to that is if you meet a girl and
she's not turned on by you,
she's a fucking lesbian.
No,
I know.
Cause you're saying that if he's not aroused by you,
he's gotta be gay.
Oh No.
That's not only where it is.
What it sounds like
sounds like that's not what I mean at all.
It's just,
it's hard to explain unless you're sitting there on that date with me.
Is it like when he talked to a black eye on the phone and even if you're super
educated,
you still know he's black.
You're terrible.
That's real.
That's some real shit.
I've talked to a lot of black guys on the phone where they were very articulate,
very intelligent,
very educated,
but I knew there were black.
That's not a bad thing.
Yeah.
It's not bad to be black.
It's nothing wrong.
I don't know what that means.
Like how dare you?
How dare you bullshit me.
National Internet program such as this,
you know,
I know and everybody listens to this,
including black people that might pretend to be offended.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
Listen to me,
there's zero wrong with being black.
Absolutely nothing.
I am the least racist person you will ever meet.
I hope I have zero racism in me,
so I don't think it's possible to get any less racist.
However,
I am a person that likes to look at reality.
I think it's interesting to find what people do and don't get offended at and
telling someone they sound black is not a bad thing,
but people sound black women and men,
I have talked to them on the phone and had wonderful elaborate conversations
that I truly enjoyed,
but I knew I was talking to a black person.
But why?
Because of their voice,
their,
the way they express themselves,
the way their,
their languages use,
the way they though the,
the tonal quality,
the way they speak.
There's a certain way that black people speak that's slightly different.
White people can speak like black people.
I have been confused that way.
Yeah.
Where I talked to the dude and he was a wigger and I thought,
I'm talking to a black guy.
It turns out that I was just talking to a white guy that really wishes he was
black.
[inaudible] super normal.
Yeah.
That happens a lot and nothing wrong with it.
That's happened with a Chinese guy.
That was a freak out.
Yeah.
I was talking to the dude on the phone and then I met him in person and I'm just
like,
oh,
he's a Chinese dude.
Oh what the fuck?
I thought I was talking to a black guy.
It was weird.
Yeah,
that is interesting.
I'm going back to the whole gay thing because I want to um,
kind of back pedal from what I said.
Disastrous.
Um,
look,
I,
I'm in a unique position because of where I live and also I'm in Los Angeles,
which means a lot of people,
a lot of guys take a lot of pride in the way they look and they are almost proud
of being overly feminine in some ways.
Like they like the moisturizer and they like the fancy clothing.
And so then in that case there,
they used to be called
Metro sexuals.
I don't know what the politically correct term is now.
Is that bad?
Is Metro sexual
see how these terms are always changing man.
Like sometimes do you think that it's a totally PC term and all of a sudden
someone will like send you an angry email?
Like how dare you refer to us as Metro sexuals but you know,
so I could be absolutely wrong.
And by the way,
I have been
known at work for having terrible Gaydar so maybe I am wrong.
Yeah,
but,
but there's just,
it's freaking tough out there.
I don't know.
I'll spell it out for you.
You're a hot chick.
If dues don't move,
you say they gotta be gay.
No,
that's not what I'm saying.
That's not what I'm saying.
You probably correct too.
And I'm not a super hot chicks,
so this isn't bad.
But that does happen.
Um,
there is a lot of gay dudes who try to pretend to be straight.
I think for society or for what have you.
They just keep it together as long as they can.
And then the fucking wheels fly off.
Yup.
And there was a guy that I used to work out with,
this guy used to work out this gym and he would talk about girls.
And the way,
the best way I could describe it is if I was speaking to you,
if you were French,
and I was saying the correct words,
but I had no idea what the fuck they meant.
[inaudible]
but obviously I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
It's just off,
you know,
rise the 40 year old virgin and how he was describing having sex.
Do you remember that scene?
You see that movie?
Oh,
there was a funny,
he was like,
oh yeah,
I remember when I like touched her breasts and they,
they felt like they felt like sandbags
and it was just so obvious that he had never had sex before
that I was talking to just start talking about this interaction that you had
with a woman in a nightclub and now this girl just came up to him.
It just started kissing him and making out with him.
And it was like the way he was saying it was like the worst,
like fake storytelling you can imagine.
It was.
He was like,
he was doing a sketch.
Yeah,
yeah.
But he was a beautiful man,
like beautiful,
like big tall,
perfect bone structure,
just handsome.
And he had this girlfriend that just always had this perplexed look at her face,
like just just look like,
like an explosion just went off like 30 seconds ago and she's trying to figure
out what the fuck happened.
Like that's how she would go everywhere.
Cause she was like,
he was like,
she was batting way over ahead with him.
He was at 10 and she was probably in the six or seven range and she was a little
on the overweight side.
It was a,
there was a,
it was a clear mismatch and it was just a gay guy who had this girlfriend but he
was gay.
I have,
um,
I can't believe I'm going to share this on the show.
My friends think it's so silly.
Okay.
I have something called the mediocre guy theory.
Um,
and the mediocre guy theory is,
do not date a guy who's overly attractive.
You're just asking for trouble because guys already have like this crazy
confidence.
Even if they're not very,
like they can't,
even if they're not the most attractive guy in the world,
usually there,
they're usually
cautious.
Let me just point out.
First of all,
you're Armenian.
Yes.
And Armenian dudes are fucking savages.
In what way?
They're the most aggressive guys on the planet.
I,
yeah.
Dudes.
We have a lot of Armenian fighters in the UFC and the fucking animals.
I A,
yeah.
I don't date Armenian guys.
Savages.
Yeah.
Those dudes are men.
Those are wild men with Harry chess who will punch you in the face.
They're fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Right.
Do you know how many people have asked me?
I've never lived in Glen Dale.
I've only been in Glendale like a few times.
I'm the most Americanized Armenian.
It would be nice to meet an Armenian guy who's as Americanized as I am,
but most of them are very traditional,
which means we're going to butt heads and I just don't,
I don't even have to wear that gold chain.
They're cross.
Yeah.
I don't play like it.
I don't play that game where the cross for Jesus.
Come on.
No,
so you're mediocre guy theory is,
yeah,
so don't,
don't go after a guy who's extremely attractive because he's going to get it.
First of all,
he's going to be constantly told that he's attractive.
He's going to constantly get attention from other women.
I don't,
I don't want to play that game.
Like I just don't want to deal with that.
You know what I mean?
So interesting.
Yeah.
Like what you just said right now about the guy who's out of her league,
right?
Let's say best case scenario,
he's not gay and straight couple or whatever.
Right.
Trust me.
But like you don't want to feel like the guy you're dating is prettier than you.
Wow.
It's really whatever.
Worry about that.
Would you ever really ever think that a guy would be pretty as a man is as,
as faithful as his opportunities.
Okay.
The believe Chris Rock joke,
it's not a joke.
It's might've been his joke,
but it's actually true.
Yeah.
Like if a guy is really attractive and he's constantly getting like bombed on.
Like women throwing themselves at him,
then he's going to cheat on you.
There's no question.
So you're better off shooting for the middle.
Yeah.
Um,
well the middle looks wise.
Yeah.
I want to look,
you've got a specific thing.
Looks are nice.
And by the way,
I'm sorry,
I'm just talking bullshit.
Like right.
I've dated really hot guys before like,
and whatever.
But what matters to me most is like the chemistry,
and I'm talking about intellectual chemistry,
physical chemistry,
like there's gotta be that connection.
Of course.
If that doesn't exist,
then I don't give a shit how good you look around.
Know that this has turned into the longest episode of the dating show.
Everyone I know.
Sorry about that.
Okay.
Those
shows were great.
They don't do those anymore.
Never have dating shows now because of stocking issues.
I remember they used to have those,
the dating game and you know,
people would,
uh,
they would be wearing those weird suits with the fucking bell bottoms and they
tell what they would do.
Bachelor number one,
if I met you and I was on a beach looking for shells and you wanted to get my
attention,
what would you say to be,
you know,
is it,
you claimed that,
I just know,
yeah,
those don't exist anymore.
No,
I don't think they can.
Yeah.
I think it's too many legal legal issues.
Yeah,
there were super cheesy anyway.
Do you,
uh,
do you find
that you meet guys like inside your community and like dating like a other
reporters or journalists or people in that world?
Um,
yeah.
I mean there have definitely been some people I've run into where I'm like,
oh my God,
you know,
he's super smart.
He's a good looking guy.
Like we should probably go out of date or whatever.
He's gay.
No,
that's not the case.
I just,
I feel weird.
I feel weird dating someone that I work with or someone that I'm going to run
into often with my career because I don't want to burn burn bridges.
It might end disastrously.
So I just don't want to do that.
And plus on top of that,
I'm,
I'm more interested in dating someone who has a completely different career than
mine because I want to learn something from someone I'm dating.
We're very lucky Brian Redman is on here right now cause he'll be fucking
throwing himself out.
We'll do this year.
We're different.
We're
totally different.
Um,
you worry at all that with the stuff that you're doing that there'll be
repercussions the ever think like when the Michael Hastings thing went down,
did you guys freak out a little bit hoarse?
What did you think happened there for folks who don't know,
tell the story of what Michael Hastings did and then what happened to him?
Michael Hastings was one of the few real journalists left in the u s he was one
of the few journalists who actually gave a shit about holding politicians
accountable for their actions and he was so driven.
He was one of the most driven people that I've ever met in my entire life.
He made me feel like shit about my career on a regular basis because he was so
inspiring and so just hardworking and determined,
you know.
So he broke the story about General Stanley Mcchrystal.
Basically,
long story short,
Stanley McChrystal was saying some crazy shit about Obama,
basically criticizing him behind closed doors.
Um,
Michael Hastings wrote a rolling stone piece about it and,
uh,
the Obama administration forced McChrystal to resign.
So that was a really big story.
Michael Hastings won awards for it and you know,
that kind of put them on the map.
He wrote many great books and he,
he was just a great journalist.
But the most important thing to keep in mind is he was one of those people who
was fearless when it came to holding the government accountable.
Okay.
And you don't see that often then all of a sudden,
you know,
in June of 2013,
he gets into this really mysterious car accident at four,
I believe,
four 20 in the morning,
four 30 in the morning around then.
And he was speeding,
uh,
in the silver Mercedes and he crashed into a palm tree and the car exploded on
impact.
And everyone was wondering whether or not this was something that was basically
orchestrated by the government or if this was a real accident.
Now in terms of,
you know,
those rumors in the conspiracy theories,
I feel very irresponsible speculating one way or another.
I don't know what happened.
No one knows what happened.
All I do know is I worked closely with him,
the young Turks,
he was
on our show often.
I cohosted a few episodes with him and I remember sitting in the makeup chair
getting ready to go on air when I found out that he had died in this car
accident.
And I've never felt the way I felt in that moment.
It was like a ton of bricks,
like had just fallen on me and I was just like tearing up and I couldn't believe
it.
And so I wanted to do an investigation.
We don't have the resources to do a full investigation into this,
but there were so many weird crazy aspects of it that didn't make sense.
Like his,
his engine being tossed so far away from his car.
The fact that the car exploded,
I contacted Mercedes Benz,
they refuse to answer any questions and I asked them,
I'm like,
look,
don't comment on the Michael Hastings Story.
Comment on what happens in your crash tests.
Is this typical of a crash?
And they would not answer any questions.
Um,
I tracked down the one witness that saw the entire accident from beginning to
end.
Um,
he,
he was Mexican.
You only spoke Spanish.
And,
uh,
we got a translator and he told us exactly what he saw and he said that Michael
Hastings was in fact speeding really,
really fast.
But that doesn't really answer any questions either because some people were
wondering whether or not the government can manipulate his car to make it
accelerate to the point where he gets into a crash.
I don't know.
Um,
I've,
I've read stories where it's possible,
but it's very,
very difficult to do.
So again,
I feel uncomfortable speculating,
but what I do know is his family,
including his brother,
um,
have said that he was increasingly paranoid leading up to the accident.
He was unstable.
His brother was really concerned that he was,
um,
you know,
abusing drugs,
which is why he flew to Los Angeles to help him out.
His brother,
I think was the last person to see him prior to the accident.
At least that's what he's alleging.
And I,
again,
I don't know what happened,
but it did have severe ramifications for people who want to be investigative
journalists because if that fear does exist,
if that is even a possibility,
it's going to deter you from doing real investigative journalism.
It's going to deter you from holding the government accountable because you know
that the NSA is watching every fucking move.
You know that if you're watching the wrong kind of porn or if you're doing
something that's a little questionable,
uh,
according to societal morals and or norms,
then the government can find that and they can leak that to the public and they
can destroy your reputation.
Do you as a journalist want to take that risk to do what a journalist is
supposed to do?
And I think a lot of people out there are unwilling to do it and I don't blame
them.
It's scary to know that the government can come after you if they want it to.
That's all.
Also,
if this is what happened.
Yeah.
And I'm not in again say that
you're doing that.
Yeah.
I think that's really important because we really don't know what happened.
I looked at it when it first happened.
I was pretty freaked out too cause I was like wow.
And I thought about it for a minute and I'm like,
this guy was going after generals,
you know,
and the,
these are people who are professional killers.
They didn't kill him for the government for a time.
They know how to do it really well.
They have friends,
they can pull favors and they can make some shit happen.
I mean it is possible.
Did it happen?
It's also possible that the dude was doing drugs and he was going crazy.
But from the stress,
the trauma of this whole thing about seeing,
thinking constantly that the government's after you,
I mean that might be just enough to get you to fucking kill yourself.
It might not have to do it.
They might have to just scare you and freak you out and get you to believe that
they're watching every move you make and waiting for their time to lower the
boom on you.
Yep.
And,
and that's,
that's basically what I'm referring to.
That paranoia alone is crippling.
It was crippling for Michael Hastings and it's crippling for people that I work
with that want to do the type of journalism that he did.
And that's why I fear for people like Glenn Greenwald.
Glenn Greenwald is,
in my opinion,
a hero.
I look up to him so much.
He's the one who broke the Edward Snowden story.
He's the one who's,
you know,
revealing things that American should know about.
What frustrates me is a lot of Americans feel that someone like Edward Snowden
is a trader.
He's not a trader.
He's telling you about how your civil liberties are being violated.
This is the kind of stuff that should make people want to stand up.
Instead of having a discussion about what we should do to stop the government
from spying on us.
We're having ridiculous conversations about whether or not Edward Snowden can be
considered a trader or an American hero.
That is a stupid conversation.
Okay,
we know the information now we know what the government is doing.
The government is indiscriminately collecting our metadata and they are holding
this information for a period of time and they can use it to intimidate you if
you're a political activist or if you're a journalist.
That intimidation is what cripples our democratic process.
So I have a lot of problems with that and I worry that there aren't going to be
many journalists left that will do what Michael Hastings was willing to do.
No doubt.
And it was a huge price of this guy had to pay.
I mean he's living in Russia now,
hiding,
doing it work.
Yeah.
Learning how to speak Russian most likely if he lives,
he's going to be there for the rest of his life.
And what kind of crazy stress is he under?
Even imagine
we had a hot girlfriend and a cushy job in Hawaii.
He left
that.
Yeah,
it was a pretty pretty bold move and the,
the information that's come out,
it's really changed the way people look at the government and,
and how they're,
how they're handling privacy,
how they're handling this idea of the war on terror and what they're willing to
do and not willing to do.
They're willing to violate everything.
I mean,
they're,
they're willing to go against the very principles of,
of privacy.
Like every principle of,
of the,
the,
the idea that you're sending someone something,
you have a password,
you log in,
they have a password,
they log in,
you send them an email.
So if someone doesn't get in there and breach it,
you're thinking that what's going on here is a completely private conversation.
But no,
no.
The government gets to look at it.
Not only that,
but some fucking employee that they kept going on and on about how he never
graduated high school.
I remember that.
Yeah.
I mean there were,
there was shitting on him and trying to demean him by saying that need ever
graduated school.
Then
why did you give them access to our private information?
What's your hire him like?
Is that unbelievable?
I didn't graduate high school.
It seems crazy.
And the worst part about it is,
I mean,
we have so many private contractors that have access to our private information.
It's fascinating.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a fascinating time.
And uh,
I think that we're moving closer and closer to some strange point in the future
where the idea of privacy is a thing of the past.
It's not,
it's nonexistent.
I think that's going to happen.
I don't,
I don't think you can avoid that.
I think that is without,
with whether it's a decade from now or two or three or whatever it is,
I think there's gonna come a point in time where the boundaries between people
and information or no law that no longer exist.
I feel like we're going to get to a point where we will just be desensitized to
all private information.
So the what people worry about most is like let's say you're not a politician,
you're just a political activist.
You might be worried that the government might use some information about you to
intimidate you and cause you to not be politically active anymore.
So it could be something like nude pictures of yourself that you emailed or it
could be the porn that you watched or whatever.
I feel like with the way things are going,
eventually we're going to get to a point where I'll,
all of our dirty laundry is just going to be out there and everyone's going to
be like,
oh,
all right,
whatever.
You know,
because you're going to be forced to,
there's going to be so much crap out there about everyone that you're just going
to have to deal with it.
Well,
that's going to be the future,
right?
That's like one generation from now or two generations,
whatever it is that those people are going to have no privacy from birth to
death.
I know,
I mean,
we're willingly were willingly putting our crop out there as it is with social
media.
Watson can,
I think it's a trend.
I think it's just like the technology trend.
I think we're moving in a certain direction and we don't,
there's no way you're going to stop it.
It's not like a,
a cultural thing like,
like,
uh,
different types of marriages are different types of,
you know,
tribal,
tribal government.
It's not like that.
It's way bigger than that and it's,
it seems to have a momentum all of its own and the momentum of information is
the ability to exchange it and share.
It gets quicker and easier constantly through time.
It does.
So you have,
you know,
you have two kids.
How do you plan on talking to them about social media?
Because I always wonder about that.
There are so many parents who like willingly put so much information about their
babies online,
which I find fascinating.
You know,
what kind of conversation do you think you're going to have with your kids when
it comes to oversharing online?
Cause I think that's an important conversation to have.
It's definitely important to let them know that what they're doing can be seen
by virtually every human being that exists.
That it's,
it's that.
It's at that point,
if you put something on a Facebook page,
essentially mean whether or not you get 14,000 hits or 14 billion,
it's,
it's really the same thing.
You're anybody that gets to that spot can get there and you got to realize that
like once you let it out there,
that's,
that's just this new weird connection where anyone can look your pictures
and if they're on Facebook they can comment and they could say weird shit and
they can,
they can be lecherous.
They can be strange.
That's the reality of the world we live in now.
You know?
I think you would definitely,
especially for girls,
you definitely want to be very careful about what you share and what you don't
share.
I mean,
how many times you go into someone's Twitter page,
they send you a tweet and you go,
let me just read their tweets.
Like sometimes people say something interesting and I'll go read their timeline.
Yeah,
let's look at their pictures.
Oh,
there's her tits.
Like what?
It's amazing that not even a porn star girls just holding her tits out,
smiling.
Like I just don't,
the Internet
get it.
I don't know if that's like a societal pressure that they're caving into or if
it's just stupid.
Right.
Maybe they just really liked Dick and they just want to comment in on a daily
basis is a lot of shipments and the best way to show them what you got.
I don't know.
I deal with way too much like crap online to put myself out there like that.
There's no way in how I would,
I talk about this a lot.
You know,
every time we do a story about some teenager who like sex did a picture of
herself and then you know it got leaked online.
I'm like,
don't take naked pictures of yourself.
Just don't fucking do it.
Don't do it under any circumstance.
I have a strict rule about that,
so or do it.
Fuck it.
What are you worried about?
Don't worry about that either.
Well,
if you're comfortable with people like sharing your naked picture because you
send a naked picture to a guy,
he is over,
he's going to show it to his friends and then he might put it online and he's
going to destroy your life.
And the thing is we still live in that puritanical society where if that naked
picture surfaces at work,
you could lose your job as a result of that.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Did you hear about the guy who got lost his job because he was mister t for
Halloween.
It was Toronto and I was like,
this country is going crazy and people like this isn't even this country.
I get it.
I know it's an expression.
He,
yeah,
I put on black face.
So they fired him.
He was a teacher [inaudible] he was trying to be mister t.
How could you be her t without blackface?
Like are you really saying this?
Is there something wrong with that?
He's wearing a fucking outfit.
It's not like he's putting on a minstrel show and sing and Mami and like got
like big fake lips and it's not,
no,
that's not what he's doing.
Yeah,
I know.
But look,
Canada might be a little different,
but black face has a really dark history,
especially in the United States.
You think if you play Mr t no I don't.
I don't think you should fire.
I do think it's bad.
I don't think you should get fired.
I don't think,
oh my God,
I don't think you should get fired.
Um,
but it's offensive.
It's offensive.
So I could still offensive for a Halloween costume.
I think it is.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
What have you wear a red face and you'd want to be an Indian.
Can you do that?
Is that offensive?
But that's pretty offensive to,
okay.
What about yellow face?
You weren't offensive to you be,
why can't you be Mr t without the black face?
People are going to get the your mystery.
That's fucking ridiculous.
Soul man.
That movie where the Guy Wore blackface through the whole movie.
Remember that?
I don't even know that movie.
So
it was an old movie.
It's on
his house.
Yes.
He Thomas.
How'd you remember that guy?
Nope.
And See,
he was before your time.
See,
Thomas Howell was one of those guys who's like these major league movie star did
a lot of big movies and then just stop doing them.
He was in like,
he was way back in like the,
what's that out?
So what side out?
How the fuck do you remember that?
Dare.
But so man,
uh,
he was,
he was in the,
the,
the outsiders or what was the one with Johnny Depp.
And was it the outsiders?
Uh,
and uh,
he played a guy who,
uh,
wore blackface and like,
pretended to be a black guy for something like to get in college or something
like that.
And uh,
I mean through the whole movie he wore blackface.
So you think that's,
there he is.
He's black,
not hilarious.
A black guy in school,
in blackface.
This was like in the 1980s.
Look at this.
He's got a Jheri curl.
Wigan.
The standard is probably a little different in movies.
Mm.
More,
more real than Holloway.
And is that what you're saying?
No,
movies are not more real than Halloween.
It's,
look,
I just,
I think that given the history of blackface and given how offensive it is to the
black community,
why,
why go there?
Why I don't understand.
I don't understand the value of it.
Okay,
so you want to look even more like Mr t or whatever it like just it's fine.
You can do it without doing the blackface.
Given our history and given how offensive it is,
just move forward.
That's hilarious.
I couldn't disagree more.
I think it's just the outfit.
I think if you're really pretending that if you are a completely non racist guy
and you put some paint on that makes you look more like an African American,
that somehow you're doing something offensive.
I think that's silly.
I think the idea of a white person pretending to be a black person,
it's just as weird as the idea of a black person pretend to be a white person.
But who gives a shit if a black guy puts white face on and does that thing that
Dave Chappelle used to do when a show or pretend to be a white man reading the
news,
you know,
with white paint on,
nobody gave a fuck.
White people were not made flesh and discriminated against and freaking lynched
and murdered.
And did you see a pineapple XRS?
Is that,
what is tropic thunder tropic thunder with Robert Downey Jr when he wears black
face through the home movie.
I did not see that fucking beautiful movie.
He played a black guy in the,
in the entire movie.
A really interesting argument.
I might reconsider my thoughts on it based on,
based on where I stand now.
I just feel like,
look,
I feel really uncomfortable with it just just because how society would make fun
of black people by making white actors put the black face on and,
and you know,
mimic them and make them seem like they were morons and they were less than,
it just has such a dark history.
So if people find it offensive,
I'm definitely empathetic toward that.
So Al Jolson basically fucked up Halloween.
That's what you're saying.
Definitely that stupid black face and racist bullshit.
I think if you're racist,
you're racist.
I think.
And if you're not racist,
then there's no,
nothing wrong with pretending to be a black person.
If you're going to be it for Halloween,
it's one thing.
If you're like mocking black people in general,
that's offensive.
But you're a guy,
a specific guy.
You're mister t,
you got gold chains on your,
it's Halloween.
Do there's Dave Chappelle pretends to be a white guy.
Reparations for slavery.
Well today,
the first real racism right there.
Yeah.
Check.
By the way,
he doesn't want to wait at all.
He does it.
That was a terrible,
just as bad as see Thomas Howell pretend to be black.
Equally confusing.
It's funny.
I don't know.
I see your point though and I appreciate it.
I appreciate that.
Where you're coming from,
it's like why do it?
It's not worth it and it's not worth it.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to be Mr t for Halloween.
Yeah.
And a I see your point where it's different in a movie I guess.
But I don't think I would,
it wouldn't bother me if one of my friends was Mr T.
I wouldn't be like,
man,
you're fucking racist Bro.
You have makeup on.
You're racist.
There was,
there was a story about these two women in England or two girls in England and
they were dressed as the world trade center on fire after the attack.
And they,
and they had um,
people like little fake people jumping out of the costume and to add insult to
injury,
they were part of this costume contest and they won.
They won best contest or a bit,
I'm sorry.
Best Costume.
Oh.
So like what amazes me is how little people think these things through before
they do it.
You see what I'm saying?
Like,
I mean,
there are some things that you just do not mess with,
and that's a perfect example of something you don't mess with.
Especially considering that there are family members that lost people as a
result of those attacks.
Family members who saw their own family members jumping off those buildings,
and then you have these two dumb asses wearing the stupid costume,
kind of making fun of that situation.
It's just there's some things you don't mess with and that's,
that's a perfect example of it.
Well,
I think it's another example of really dumb people getting together and
convincing each other that everything's going to be cool.
Yeah.
Oh God,
it's such a great idea,
isn't it?
Look,
I have fire,
but apparently not amazing.
Their little bubble.
It was a great idea because they won.
Yeah.
You could pull that off if you lived in a small town in Alaska before the
Internet.
Yeah,
yeah.
When people didn't know any better.
That's true.
But now,
especially if that picture goes on Facebook or something like that.
Oh,
prepare yourself,
ma'am.
Yeah.
The avalanche of hate Asiana Airlines pilot costume,
maybe most offensive of 2013.
Who is that?
I don't know the story.
The pilots have crashed.
The pilots,
that plane that crashed in San Francisco a couple months ago.
What was there?
Oh,
they dressed as the pike just put on blood on their face and they were just very
tasteless.
Oh,
okay.
Oh God.
They,
they touch,
they just don't.
Why?
Why are people so dumb?
People are dumb.
They're just dumb.
They to be shocking to,
they
want to be paid attention to.
And if you go as like the hulk,
no one's going to give a fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a million of those out there,
but if you go as this,
people go,
oh my God,
what are you doing?
And then they pay attention to you.
That's what it is.
Yup.
They just want to get a little shock just to get a little rise out of people.
Yeah.
It's true.
Um,
Julianna hough,
who was one of the dancing with the stars,
uh,
performers or whatever,
she dressed in black face.
And I feel like,
I feel like you should hold publics public figures to a higher standard because
I think you're more aware of this kind of shit.
Like more aware of the kind of criticism you're going to get.
You know what I mean?
Like your,
you're putting yourself out there,
people are going to see you.
And,
and so I,
I almost feel as though,
what is she supposed to be?
She's supposed to be one of the characters from orange is the new black,
I forget the character's name.
Um,
and she doesn't really look black.
She looks more bronze.
And I like,
she looks like she got a really bad fake Tan.
She went like to West Hollywood and got a spray Tan.
Yeah.
One of them real ones.
Um,
and so she was like,
what?
Oh my God,
I had no idea.
I apologize.
And she had this apology and like that I felt like was a little bit of a
publicity stunt.
That's my speculation.
Yeah.
Probably most likely we'll probably,
there's a lot of people are just dumb and that's not as dark as like one of
those bodybuilder women when they get that spray tan stuff like
yeah.
Really,
really dark.
Are you into that?
Oh yeah.
You are?
No.
Does it turn you on?
Not into girls that would potentially kick my ass.
Yeah.
Or be more manly than me.
My favorite discussions on this show usually center around like the appropriate
way a female body parts should look.
I don't remember who your guest was,
but you guys were talking about the appropriate look.
I know it was Jim Norton like it was Jim Norton.
Dirty bastard.
Yeah.
And uh,
that was after I was confirmed to come on your show and I remember talking to my
friend Christian,
who loves your show by the way,
Christian Lopez.
He wanted me to say hi.
Oh,
what's up?
There you go.
Um,
and I was like,
what the fuck did I just get myself into right now?
Give out a bad impression.
No,
not at all.
You're totally fine.
I'm like,
yeah,
well we do.
We do give out a bad impression.
If you wanted to cherry pick shit out of our past,
you know,
things that we've done on this show.
Yeah,
I could look,
I could look a little sketch.
Yeah.
Well I mean that's true if you cherry pick,
but people like to compare you to Howard Stern.
I actually don't think you're like Howard stern at all.
I think that you're a little more intelligent.
Howard Stern's a brilliant man.
He is a brilliant man.
Wrong.
Yeah,
he is.
I think that the topics you choose to talk about our little more intelligent,
well you know,
he does a lot of pop.
Yeah.
You know,
interviews,
a lot of artists and he,
he's really good at getting them to talk and say things.
Maybe they ordinarily that they went.
But you know,
I mean I think he's also got a much larger audience and there's also a bunch of
people behind him that probably would kinda like want him to talk about certain
subjects.
But I have,
you know,
we started this out just on the laptop and I don't really give a fuck what other
people are interested in.
I give a fuck when I'm interested in and this whole thing started out just for
fun.
So if I,
like yesterday I had a,
a real astronaut on,
I mean I had that dude who was on the,
uh,
did he leave a book now?
He didn't,
he sold send it to us.
He was on the space station for 166 days and it was really fucking interesting
stuff.
Yeah,
it was fascinating.
Uh,
Chris Hadfield,
he's uh,
he's awesome.
He was a,
that was like a real honor.
Like that to me is like,
that's the kind of people that I want to talk to.
I just want to talk to fascinating people.
Yeah.
Chris Ryan,
the guy who were,
we were looking at,
this is a photo
before.
Yeah,
I love Chris Ryan.
He's great.
He's been on our show several times and he's just really interesting.
I love his openness about sexuality and you know,
what humans are actually,
you know,
physically driven to do,
biologically driven to do.
And it's very different from societal norms and expectations.
So there's always that conflict there.
Or just a standup comedian or just a an MMA fighter or just a friend.
I mean,
I've had just friends on it.
It's just I,
I th I think too many people are out there trying to get the attention of,
of,
of people by like having people on that are famous or having people on there,
you know,
pop culture in that.
Interesting.
To tap into sometimes and find out what makes them tick.
But yeah,
for me,
I want to talk to like Neil degrasse Tyson.
I want to,
I want to talk to Sam Harris.
I want to talk to brilliant people.
I want to talk to people and pick their brain.
And people that don't normally hear on the radio or don't normally hear
interviewed on television shows.
Yeah.
I mean,
and going back to the discussion we had on new media,
that's what millennials respond to better.
Um,
they like the interviews with real people or are brilliant people who are trying
to make a difference in the world.
They liked that way more than,
you know,
the celebrity bullshit because of celebrity stuff's fun to,
it's fun.
It's fun,
but it's snacks.
Yeah.
I mean I think millennials will take that for what it's worth,
but they're more interested in change.
I and I,
and that's the reason why most of them voted for Obama because he kept preaching
change even though we didn't really get any of it.
Um,
so the leg of a good,
like we've stern interviews like Corey Feldman,
I'm going to listen to that.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm going to hear it.
I'm there for the train wreck.
Oh,
I remember very recently,
um,
Howard stern interviewed Sharon Osborne,
one person that I couldn't possibly care less about and it was such a
fascinating interview and I was like,
that's the magic of Howard Stern.
He can,
he can make any interview interesting because he will ask inappropriate
questions.
Digs into your psyche with someone like Sharon Osborne,
you know,
Ozzy Osborne.
What the fuck is going on there?
I don't know.
Uh,
yeah.
Madness,
craziness.
That is madness and craziness.
Yeah.
The uh,
the idea of having a podcast is,
I mean I never
really thought that I would ever have a radio show cause I always kind of
figured like,
no,
I always enjoyed going on morning radio and I always enjoyed it when I would go
and do standup,
I would come in early to promote and you do radio,
like back in the days before the Internet,
that's how you sold tickets.
And I always had a good time on the air and said,
wow,
that'd be cool to have a radio show.
But then I was like,
Yo,
who the fuck is going to give me a radio job?
And that's not going to happen.
And on top of that,
they're going to tell me,
I can't swear and that shit's going to get tired.
And then satellite radio came along and I started doing the opiate Anthony show
a lot.
And uh,
those guys are great and they're,
the way they have it set up is a lot like this show where it's just a
conversation.
Yeah.
They don't have like a specific agenda.
They don't have games they want to play.
All Right Anna,
it's time to play.
What would you rather do?
You know,
they don't have that kind of stupid shit.
It's just nice.
It's just a conversation it just to hang.
And so that's really what sort of,
uh,
fueled getting this thing started.
But that was,
so you have a three hour long show.
Do you ever have a difficult time weighing my bladder?
Well,
yes,
that's a,
that's a good question.
But on top of that,
um,
it's really difficult to find guests that are willing to have a three hour long
conversation.
Yeah.
Well,
yes and no.
You know,
we don't have a hard time finding guests,
but um,
yeah,
some people are just not,
it's not right for them.
Some people don't want to talk for three hours because if you talk for three
hours long enough,
people are going to find out who the fuck you really are.
Yeah,
that's true.
It just takes time.
Yeah.
You know,
and they're going to find out what tweaks you or what,
you know,
what you like,
what you don't like,
what's weird about you.
They get to know you like very,
very deeply.
Do you think your audience has a good sense of my,
my weird,
yeah,
you're worse.
Yeah.
It's super weird,
right?
It's good.
You're a nice person.
That's all that matters.
Being a nice person.
The weird thing is like,
who the fuck's not weird?
You know what I mean?
Everyone's weird.
Everyone's got their little habits and stuff.
I was talking to my friend about how important it is to be open minded,
especially at this point in our lives.
Like when we're,
you know,
willing to meet new people and make new friends and all that other stuff and
like you come across people that have certain habits that are just strange.
And when I was younger I'd be like,
Ugh,
I just want,
I don't want anything to do with this person.
And now I love this.
I love that I've grown into this person where,
where,
where I will step back,
I'll realize that something's weird and it'll make me uncomfortable.
I'll ask why it makes me uncomfortable and I'll be like,
all right,
that's fine.
It's not something that's going to hurt me or damage me,
so live with it.
It doesn't bother me.
Like if you're out with people and they're holding hands and you're like,
so what's your deal?
And like,
oh,
we're swingers,
where to go
swim call.
I get,
I mean,
if you're swingers,
like I'm,
I don't want to join you guys,
but no one does,
but do you?
Yeah.
And you're always disgusting humans.
I don't know.
I've actually never met swingers.
Swingers in my whole life.
Like,
yeah,
out now.
Tell me they were swingers,
like introduce themselves.
Swingers.
One of them,
Ari and I were in Nashville.
We were doing stand up and this guy was driving us around for two days and uh,
he was a limo driver.
And did was like,
yes sir.
No Sir.
And then finally he's dropping us off at the airport and the dude just opens up
the flood gates and just starts talking about swing in and what he,
what he does and what he likes to do.
And you know,
I don't really like to watch my wife get fucked,
but uh,
sometimes she likes watching me have sex and you know,
I don't,
if I don't feel comfortable about a guy,
I can tell her no.
We were like,
what?
Like how do what?
I wonder what kind of guys he's uncomfortable with.
Big Ones probably.
Yeah.
He's,
he's probably a fan of the mediocre guy theory.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You don't want to let your girlfriend get gorilla fuck by some giant linemen in
front of you.
You know?
That would be horrendous.
That was,
that's the last thing you want.
So he can like give the red light.
He's,
he won't,
he was saving himself for a guy who was coughing.
Oh.
Someone,
a man with a limp,
you know,
take him hunting.
He'll show you a good looking guy.
Yeah.
Just try to find some guy who's like less endowed than you fear older than you.
That's understandable though.
You don't want to deal with that competition I guess.
Just sad.
Um,
we had a conversation about like furries on the show before.
Oh yeah.
And so I don't see anything wrong.
I mean,
I don't prefer furries,
don't get me wrong,
but like whatever they like to dress up as animals when they're having sex.
Like I don't care.
That doesn't bother me.
Like if I found out someone I'm hanging out with his into that,
then I would just be like,
all right,
you're into that.
It's totally fine.
Really.
So if you're dating a guy and you found out that he was into being a furry and
he would go to furry conventions,
they'd sniff each other's fake butts,
bounce around like squirrels.
You'd be like,
that's fine.
I don't have a problem with that.
Come on.
You would judge him.
I don't,
I'm not in that.
Okay.
I would like to say that I would not judge him.
I would judge the shit out of a girl if I was dating and I was a,
and I met a girl and we're hanging out and she's pretty cool.
And then she's like,
well this is one thing that I really liked to do.
I like to pretend to be a chipmunk mascot and uh,
I put on my chip Monck mascot outfit on and I go to these conventions in
Pittsburgh.
We all fly in with our furry outfits on and we danced around together and we
planned that pretend to have sex,
but no one really penetrates anybody.
Um,
yeah,
I look,
it is what it is.
I feel like there definitely,
there are worse fetishes out there like guys who like to wear diapers and they
like to get changed.
Like that kind of stuff scares the hell out of me.
How do you even preach that conversation?
I don't even know.
I,
I don't know how I give them like furries for instance.
I give them props because how do you find someone who's willing to deal with
your fetish?
Well,
I think there's something in being willing to deal with almost anything that's
like,
it's extra attractive.
You have to be open minded.
Yeah.
Well when people start dating each other,
this is my thing,
my,
my thinking on it is that when,
when people start dating each other,
if someone really wants someone to be a part of their life,
they might like want to do something like really weird with them to show them
that do not care.
I'll do anything.
I'll change your diaper.
I'll wipe your butt.
Oh my God.
Like I remember a dude that I know he would take,
we were at a,
um,
a fight.
It was backstage.
Uh,
my,
my friend was warming up in the green room and this dude went into the bathroom
with his girlfriend and took a shit like in front of her.
It's like little bathroom together and I go,
did you just take a shit in front of a really?
Cause I went in there afterwards.
It was horrible.
He wrecked the bathroom.
Oh,
why,
why?
But I asked him,
I go,
what's that about?
He goes,
we do everything together,
man.
We do everything together.
No,
that's not healthy.
That's not healthy though.
But that's,
that's how can you say it's not,
and you can say where the fucking furry outfit is,
but that there's like a codependency issue there that's not healthy.
If you have to do everything together,
that would be my nightmare.
My goal in life is to find a guy that is comfortable with me living my life and
not just Jews right now writing on Twitter.
I
know your life and I feel like sometimes like my issue is I'm too like wrapped
up in my career bubble and I'm really attracted to like independent guys that
don't want a girl who's like always on him.
Like guys,
guys pretend like they don't like that,
but they do.
They want a girl who's all about him all the time and I'm just not that kind of
person.
Especially if you have your own career.
Yeah,
I assume.
And convenient.
I love it.
Is it,
is it inconvenient?
Some people,
um,
I love like independent,
strong people.
Like that's the biggest turn onto me,
mommy.
I like,
I'm weak.
Dependent,
a lot of,
a lot of people do.
I like that.
I like when people get sick a lot.
People need you to give them soup.
And a lot of people do like that.
Co dependency is a real issue.
Yeah,
well people want,
I mean,
isn't that really the mediocre guy theory that you want to make sure it doesn't
go anywhere?
No.
Sort of similar.
And by the way,
just to be completely crystal clear,
my mediocre guy theory is a little bit of a joke like Austin,
like obviously I don't want a mediocre guy and obviously I want a guy that I'm
physically attracted to.
But I do believe that a guy is as faithful as his opportunities.
Same goes for women,
by the way.
It's not just men,
those dirty bitches.
I can't believe you're saying that.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
It's especially human beings when they're not.
Like,
if you're not,
if you,
if you haven't found someone that enthralls you or someone that you're like
deeply locked in with,
it's real easy.
So like lose a relationship,
but you got a relationship and it's like,
you know,
uh,
I'm not investing any more time in this.
And then boom,
and guys are always worried about the music ending and then being left without a
chair and you're like,
hey,
you know,
you're playing musical chairs.
The music stops and there's nowhere to sit down and then no one wants me.
And that's that thing,
that thing that a lot of people want someone to want them.
And if they're dating an independent woman,
they realize like this check whether she enjoys your company or not.
She could
do without you,
dude.
And she's fine.
You know that that freaks guys out.
A lot of guys,
they want some girl who's like waiting by the phone when you call her.
Oh my God,
I was so happy you called.
Should I say that?
You know,
they,
they love stoop year.
That's such a hard buying it for a second.
No,
it's true.
It's just the same reason why like people pretend they like to fight.
Like men,
like always say like,
Oh,
if I knew if I was a black belt,
I'd go to the UFC,
kick everybody's ass.
Now that's not what you're,
you don't understand what you're saying.
What you're saying is you would like to beat somebody up,
but you don't really actually want to fight because the fighting is fucking
brutal and somebody might beat you up.
You could lose.
It's not guaranteed.
It's a risky wild.
The,
the,
the whole thing.
The whole,
the whole proposition is incredibly risky.
So are relationships.
Relationships are unbelievably risky.
Of course.
A lot of people don't even want to enter in relationship.
They just want to smash it.
They just want to go in there and kick somebody's ass the same way they want to
go in there and kick somebody's ass in a fight and not actually be in a fight.
They don't want to date some girl's smart intelligence going to see through my
bullshit and I can't use all the stuff that I learned in my pickup artist's book
that I've been reading for the past six months.
You're gonna see right through that and that,
and you're going to,
you know,
pick out the flaws and all my arguments.
Fuck that.
I'm just looking for a dumb chick with a limp that I could dominate for a short
amount of time and then bail.
That is a sexy man right there.
It's a week dude.
But there's a lot of them.
And it's because people were scared of failure.
Some really like strong,
intelligent,
confident men.
Um,
and I love that they exist.
They exist.
They're like,
they're very,
very rare.
But they exist.
I know.
I should,
I shouldn't even say they're very,
very rare.
How do I know?
It's not like I've been dating like a billion guys.
Right.
But they exist.
And,
and,
and when I say that I liked the independence,
it doesn't mean like I don't need him.
It means this person makes me a better person and I want to make him a better
person.
We have this strong bond,
this strong partnership,
but we don't suffocate each other.
I think a lot of relationships are suffocating.
And I want to avoid that at all costs.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's,
it's tough to not be suffocating sometimes if you're scared and you're clinging
onto the last piece of wood you found floating in the ocean.
Yeah.
After the horrible wreck of the rest,
the last x amount of years of your life,
that's a lot of people.
You run into them.
You're not just running into a person,
you're running into a person.
It's just getting back on their feet from some whatever,
fucking disaster,
whatever it was,
whatever breakup,
whatever you know,
home,
repossession,
last job.
What?
What is the crisis that you just recently survived and just washed up on shore
and now you're meeting that person.
So let me,
you meet someone in their thirties oh my God.
You're meeting a lot of shit.
You meeting a lot of shits,
a lot of years.
It's not a bad thing.
Some people are better for it though.
I mean,
there's the bright side of it.
Some people,
because of all those disasters,
they develop character and they understand what's good and not good,
what,
how they should behave,
what are the ramifications of different kinds of behaviors.
Yeah.
The,
yeah.
You find that out,
but you know how many of you will learn from their mistakes?
Half,
half of them to 50% of the people learn at least half.
I hope.
I would hope,
but I don't think it's even 40 I think it's probably like 30 the rest of the
people are just banging their heads on coconut trees.
People are crazy.
They are crazy.
I just,
I feel like it's better to look if you don't meet someone that makes you feel
good about yourself and you do the same for them.
I feel like it's just better to be alone and live your life and wait.
If be an old lady with a lot of cats in a vibrator,
fine.
Maybe not the cats vibrator.
Sure.
Why not?
Did you see that new,
a oculus rift thing that they have?
Oh,
the three d reality goggles.
They've come up with one now that allows you to have sex and it connects you to
some sort of an artificial thing that's like a fleshlight.
It's moving up.
No,
I know nothing about that.
But I have like read stories about robots that they're creating that are very
lifelike.
So,
you know,
women will be useless in and you know,
10 years or something when these are perfected in Japan.
I'm just,
I'm kidding about the women being useless
for some men.
There'll be something that they won't have the effort to pursue anymore.
Right.
That's going to be real.
I've talked,
I've talked to a guy who cannot wait.
I cannot wait for these sex robots to be perfected.
Um,
so,
and,
and he's like totally honest about it.
He's like,
yeah,
there's so lifelike that you can like have a relationship with a sex robot.
And it's like,
I don't,
I don't even know what my response should be to that.
That worries always be an empty hollow relationship.
There's always going to be something missing from it.
You're always going to want to have sex with them maybe.
Yeah.
But if they look like super hot and they're robots,
but hanging out with them,
there's gonna come a point in time when you realize that this is just a bunch of
circuits and it's just a bunch of electrical impulses going through a board,
definitely staring at you and coming at you with some prerecorded voice.
Yeah.
It's going to be weird.
People are always going to the part of what people like about people is that
we're all in this crazy thing together.
Yeah,
that's true.
And,
and you know,
going back to the necessity of human interaction,
um,
in some Asian countries,
they,
prostitutes offers something called the girlfriend experience and they probably
do that here in the United States too.
But I distinctly remember talking about it in Korea,
I believe.
And,
um,
they don't just have sex with the guys.
Like they,
in some cases,
they never have sex with the guys.
The guys will pay for the girl to be like a girlfriend where she's like
nurturing and caring and cuddles with him and watches movies with him and stuff
like that.
And that actually gave me a little bit of faith in humanity because that showed
me that there are people out there that just want that.
You know that connection.
They want more than that physical,
raw interaction.
They want something emotional.
Yeah,
there's always going to be that,
but they would like to fuck as well.
That's true.
The problem is a lot of times the girlfriend experience is 50 bucks.
Whereas the other thing,
if you want to actually have sex like 125 so you have to budget your,
you know,
if you're living in Japan and a tiny bit,
you're not buying it like you think,
no,
this guys are,
they're cuddling because they do want a cuddle,
but they definitely want to move to the next level.
I don't think you're giving guys enough credit.
I think that guys,
I,
they liked,
they like to pretend like they don't have any emotional connection or want that
emotional connection,
but a lot of them want,
Oh yeah,
no,
don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying that men definitely want an emotional connection with a
girlfriend or a wife or a woman in their life.
What do you know?
Label it in any way you want,
but they also wanna fuck.
So yeah,
but if they can't get that,
if all they can get as coddling,
they'll say it's a calling,
but they would like a little bit more.
This is natural.
Why would someone be affectionate with me but not want to please me all the way
or get rid of this throbbing thing.
Oh,
that's just a natural,
I mean it's his natural as like,
you know,
eating one piece of your food and wanting to eat the rest of it.
Yeah,
it's natural.
It's completely natural.
Yeah.
So like there was a thing recently where a woman was like making $90 an hour
cuddling with people.
She was like,
hi,
hi girl.
Out to cuddle with people.
That's,
I mean I couldn't do it but make money.
All I was thinking of like what a dangerous situation that is for the girl to be
with some man holding onto her like in,
in like very close proximity.
Like how many guys are just going to start beating off on her back.
You know how many guys are going to be cuddling with her and tried to rape her?
It's like I wouldn't trust a guy to cuddle with them like that.
I he has a guy wouldn't trust a guy.
Yeah,
we're not coddling dude.
I don't,
I don't know what the legality of that is,
but it does go back to the whole prostitution issue and how important it is to
legalize and regulate it and create a safe environment for women to do that type
of stuff so you can actually mitigate or minimize,
you know,
those types of instances where a guy will be abusive or do something degrading
or demeaning.
The worry is also,
I mean always that you're promoting it and then a few make prostitution,
legal and the people of God,
a prostitution that would never go to prostitution before.
So what
kind of woman are you?
Who are you?
I have a woman with an open fire with those lawyer women and all of you sell
your vagina's down the river.
Just sell them.
I just feel like people who want to have relations with a prostitute or going to
do it anyway.
And if legalizing prostitution somehow convinces someone who wouldn't otherwise
go to a prostitute to go through with it,
then okay.
Like there are worse things in the world.
It's just,
it's sad.
So what I agree with,
you mean obviously playing devil's advocate,
but yeah.
What was it that being on the show changed where you had this shift in your
attitude about legalized prostates?
I worried about the safety of the women that put themselves in that situation
and also the safety of men that put themselves in that situation.
Because if you regulate it,
you can ensure that these women are getting tested for STDs.
You don't want a bunch of people getting,
you know,
AIDS or other sexually transmitted diseases,
pregnant,
you know,
a regulated industry.
This case would be much better than yeah.
You know,
criminalizing it and allowing people to harm themselves or be put in a harmful
situation.
And on top of that,
here's another thing I don't want to do.
I don't want to waste our resources on incarcerating people for these.
So called sex crimes because I don't see prostitution as a sex crime.
I see it as a normal human behavior.
People want sex.
Some people unfortunately have to pay for sex.
But if,
if that transaction has to happen,
let it happen.
Let it be regulated.
Let's get it off the streets and put it in a place that's safer.
That's just better for society.
No,
that's a totally rational way of looking at it.
Yeah.
And um,
unfortunately we have this weird attitude when it comes to sexuality and we have
this weird attitude when it comes to naked people.
I mean,
remember that Janet Jackson thing,
we showed a nickel on the super super bowl and everybody lost their fucking
mind.
Yup.
I remember.
We're really weird in that way.
It's okay to give someone a massage.
You could rub their feet to the cows.
Come home with oil.
You could rub them.
They can moan out loud.
Oh my God,
it smells so good.
Nobody has a problem with it.
Rubbed my back,
rub my,
but don't touch my dick.
Whoa.
That's a crime.
Even though it would feel fantastic if you did,
can't do it.
He's against the book
sitter.
That cheating.
Like if you are married and um,
you will,
you are married.
But like if you were to go to a massage parlor and get that done,
would that be considered cheating?
I definitely think it would get you in a lot of trouble.
Of course it would get you into a lot is like a,
it seems like someone would not be happy about that,
but it would be awesome if they were,
if you could just go and what if they wear a mask?
Like one of those Mexican wrestlers,
they even know what they look like.
You go in there with like a wolf man mask on and then they could dress like a
Mexican wrestler.
You don't even look at each other.
You both wear sunglasses it seems so it's just like a massage in a situation
like that.
It's really not that different.
That's the reason why they do it at a massage parlor.
Right.
You know,
and the real,
the guys pro tips guys actually get a massage and then get a happy ending.
They don't just go right for the happy ending.
The,
the,
the legit pros,
they sit there,
they have a real massage first.
How the Japanese do it
come up.
Like how do you find a massage parlor that is willing to do that?
There's websites.
There are,
yes.
Yeah.
Fascinating websites that'll tell you where the spots are and you know,
like they'll rate places with stars and detailed their hand job experiences.
Wow.
And of course it doesn't just stop at a hand job.
It goes further than that in some cases.
Right.
Allegedly allegedly made.
Yeah.
It's,
it's one of those weird things where we've decided that people can do it for
free and no one gets hurt.
Yeah.
But if they do it for money,
it's illegal.
And then the,
I,
the,
the logic behind it is very weird.
And the logic behind the laws are,
you know,
there's,
there's more Allity ideas,
there's ethics ideas.
The reality
is that money is going to be changing hands,
whether you like it or not.
And most likely it's not going to get taxed unless it's legal.
Yeah.
It's just gonna it's gonna move into the economy.
And some sort of a weird way,
but the government in that,
in and also in drug laws,
they're fucking themselves out of massive amounts of revenue.
I know more on drugs is the most colossal fucking failure of a war in the hit
you guys during the time you're at war,
the business got bigger.
It got way huge,
are everywhere in the world.
It's a huge part of the economy and the business is become medical in
California,
very 16 other states,
legal in two states now,
now legal in Portland,
Maine.
It's the worst
failure of a war ever.
It is.
And when you look at the war on drugs,
specifically the war on marijuana,
very little of it has to do with stopping people from using these drugs.
Most of it has to do with paying for correctional officers,
paying for private prisons,
paying for private contractors,
even private contractors abroad who continue to amplify the war on drugs.
People are making a ton of money off this prohibition,
which is why it continues and it will never stop.
And I love that we're seeing the snowball effect with the legalization of
recreational marijuana or recreational use of marijuana.
Um,
there was recently a small town in the east coast that legalize it,
I believe it was in Maine.
Portland,
Maine.
Yeah,
it was Portland,
Maine.
They just legalized it and it was more of a symbolic thing because of course,
state laws and federal laws will Trump,
you know,
whatever municipal laws have been passed.
But I love that now politicians are forced to pay attention to the polls and
make changes because we're spending untold amounts of money just incarcerating
people for simple marijuana possession.
It's hideous.
It is in the real problem with the war on drugs being with when you have
marijuana illegal,
it means you're not getting that tax money from it.
Just like you're not getting it from prostitution.
You,
the government doesn't get their cut.
They're not getting it.
It's going to make its way into the economy.
In some ways,
like in BC,
in British Columbia,
there there's a huge issue because a giant chunk of their economies based on
marijuana,
but yet marijuana is illegal.
They arrest people.
But then let them go.
There's like a lot of weird fucking games going on up there,
but because it's illegal,
they're not getting their taxes from it.
It's a huge issue.
They know it's a giant.
There was a documentary that I was in called the union and it was all about,
that's what they call it.
They called the union.
When they talk about the,
the,
all the different marijuana growers in BC.
It's like they're a multibillion dollar part of the economy up there.
So it's this weird hypocrisy that's going on where you have this thing that's a
huge part of why everybody's doing well.
Yep.
And that's things illegal and that thing's hurting no one.
And by the way,
because it's illegal,
you're not getting your cut.
Do you know I'm about the Shaffer report.
What's that?
During the,
Oh,
I love this story.
I love telling this story.
So during the Nixon administration,
Nixon wanted to commission a study on marijuana specifically.
Do you know about it?
Know about the Knicks and report Yada.
Yeah.
So he commissioned,
I believe he was a governor at the time as a politician.
With the last name,
Schaefer,
um,
to do the study on marijuana.
So Shaffer,
go,
went ahead and did it.
And he found that marijuana had no real long term negative effects on society or
human health or anything like that.
It just was not a threat to society,
period.
Nixon,
the same freaking person who commissioned that report took it,
ripped it up and said,
no,
I'm going to amplify the war on drugs.
I'm going to continue making this legal illegal.
I'm going to continue criminalizing people who have simple possession of it.
And Nixon,
I mean,
of course he did a lot of hideous things,
but that had so many negative ramifications in the country.
That's what led to this explosion of the for profit prison industry.
And now that industry,
first of all,
I don't know why it's called for profit or private prisons because they're
funded by tax dollars.
So how are they private?
And on top of that,
now we have an incentive to lock people away because these companies make money
off of it.
It's sick.
Yeah.
Private prisons are very scary.
It's very scary that not only do we have private prisons,
but you have private prison lobbies and you have guard lobbies were prison
guards.
Make sure that certain things stay illegal so that they can ensure that they
have work.
Yeah,
that slaves,
you're making slaves.
I mean you,
you want people to be locked up more than not locked up.
In my opinion,
if it's not robbery or violent crime,
those are the two things that I'm worried about.
Robbery or violent crime.
That's when you need to remove people from society.
Everything else should be on some sort of a penalty thing.
Yeah,
I mean the IBS demeanor,
citations,
what is it?
What's going on?
I mean,
did,
what did you not do?
Did you not pay your taxes?
Why do you get locked up for that?
That sounds crazy.
Why don't don't you just owe taxes.
How about you make them pay?
Because when you learned them making any money,
why are you profiting off?
How are you doing that?
You're locking them up and that's better than getting money from them while
they're,
yeah,
working.
Well,
we're doing the same thing with people who are undocumented immigrants,
right?
So they'll come into this country,
they're undocumented.
We find out they're undocumented.
And instead of deporting them,
which is what we used to do,
we will detain them for x amount of years and spend our resources on imprisoning
them,
which doesn't make any sense at all.
And I get it like you,
you might.
Okay.
We want to punish them and show them like,
you can't,
you can't do this again,
but you punish them by deporting them.
You know what I mean?
And,
and that's it.
Like,
why would you want to incarcerate them and spend tax dollars on that?
Especially when we're having this huge issue with public education right now.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a weird little fake thing that we have going on where we pretend that la
doesn't have 10 million illegal immigrants.
We just kind of like,
Whoa,
you know,
whatever.
Now they're allowed to go to college.
At least there's a long time where,
uh,
immigrants,
where are children of immigrants or immigrants that came over and their children
were born in Mexico but live their entire lives here in America.
They weren't allowed to go to college.
I know.
So I'm happy that California passed the Dream Act.
It's ridiculous that we haven't been able to do that
federal level.
Yeah,
absolutely disgusting.
What is America?
It's not a nation of immigrants.
I mean that,
that's all we are.
We are a bunch of people that came here from other put into penalize a baby or
to say that,
well,
you know what?
The parents,
they brought the kid over here so the kid can sponge off the kids a part of the
fucking system.
Yeah.
They call them anchor babies.
By the way.
The parents are part of the system to,
they're working here.
Yeah.
I hate the argument that they don't pay taxes in a lot of cases,
especially in California.
I mean they pay taxes in the form of,
first of all,
they pay social security,
but then they never get a dime of that social security later.
Right.
So there are contributing to the social security system.
And on top of that they're paying for state taxes as well or sales taxes.
Yeah.
So they do pay taxes,
they do contribute to society.
And I'm not trying to,
you know,
make excuses or to justify coming into the country illegally.
But if you've been here for decades and you've had your children here,
there,
we need to create some sort of comprehensive immigration reform.
And right now we have clowns and office that can't seem to agree on anything and
refuse to work with one another.
So I feel like it's going to be difficult for that to happen.
But I feel like something like the dream act is common sense.
It shouldn't even be a political issue.
It shouldn't be a partisan issue.
You should just do it.
Yeah,
I completely wholeheartedly agree.
And I think there's also this weird thing where we're connected to a third world
country by a fence.
I mean we are right next door to the biggest war on drugs and all of the world
playing out on our border.
And then right across there you have intense,
extreme poverty.
If you take a car from San Diego,
you can go from La Jolla where you will have the most elegant clifftop mansions
that will blow your mind.
Just these great Gatsby houses.
We like,
oh my goodness.
Like this fucking giant circular driveway with enormous found you like what a
house in 20 minutes you're in Tiawana 20 fucking minutes and you might just just
get there while these cartel members are dropping off headless bodies in the
lining them up on the street with signs on them or you know,
you might see a brothel where you can go fuck some immigrant for a a dollar that
made their way up from El Salvador or,
or Peru or Mexico is the promise land for them.
There are hoping to get to Mexico because they live in the jungle somewhere in
Ecuador.
They,
I mean it's the extreme intense poverty and extreme intense violence and we're
just sort of like not dealing with it.
We're not dealing with it,
but we're actually fueling that type of system here in the United States
by keeping marijuana illegal.
We certainly are keeping
marijuana illegal and also through our current fiscal policy,
you know,
by allowing companies like Walmart to basically pay full time employee so little
that the government has to subsidize their healthcare or food stamps,
whatever it is,
just so they can make ends meet like we have,
we have that system here now and we need to do something to change.
That's exactly what they were protesting about during the WTO thing.
It goes all back to Alex Jones.
I told you Joe Rogan
that that's what he was,
uh,
his,
his document,
I think it was nine one,
one a road to tyranny.
It was all about that.
It was all about how this is like an established pattern of behavior and you
know,
this agent provocateur thing that they do to break up peaceful protests.
The World Trade Organization meeting was just about that very thing.
This is about moving jobs to these other places and figuring out how to set up
shop and third world countries.
You can pay people dirt wages.
Yeah.
I don't know how that's going to get fixed.
Do you,
when you,
when you cover this stuff on a daily basis,
I mean you guys are covering more serious issues and we are mover basically just
fucking around and finding things in the Internet that I find are interesting.
But you guys are like covering like some pretty legit stories and getting pretty
in India.
Do you see any light at the end of the tunnel?
Do you see like a pot of gold at the end of the rainbow for all this?
I do see a light at the end of the tunnel,
but we really need a revolution and I'm not calling for violence and I'm not
inciting violence.
But I think that there has to come a point where we hit rock bottom and the
political activism actually makes a difference.
You know,
the political activism needs to exist to begin with,
by the way,
because it doesn't even exist now.
I mean,
we're at a point where the government can literally do whatever it wants and no
one will make a peep out of it.
The NSA can spy on us.
The Obama Administration can go drop a drone or do a drone strike on an American
citizen and his 16 year old son and no one will say a damn thing about it.
That's the country we're living in right now.
Or civil liberties are being destroyed.
Our fiscal policy.
Does it make sense?
We need people to be politically active and we need to get money out of
politics.
Those are the two things that mattered the most.
Do you think there's also the aspect of the,
the amount of information that we're getting overwhelmed with on a daily basis?
When you think about a story about the American citizen that was targeted,
that was the,
the,
the Ottawa or I'll,
I'll walk hottie got.
Yeah.
And it killed his son with drones and you know,
he was an American.
I mean,
they didn't try them.
They just assassinating them.
Uh,
is there too many stories coming in?
I mean,
go to cnn.com right now and you'll see a fucking million of them on the front
page.
Yeah,
no,
go to Yahoo.
Go to all these new sites and you're like,
God damn,
that's,
that's part of the problem.
But I mean the,
most of these stories are important news stories.
Yeah.
There's a lot of bullshit sprinkled in there.
Um,
but a huge problem is,
you know,
every American I,
I'm,
I have the luxury of keeping up with this stuff because it's my job.
A lot of Americans don't have that luxury because they're working 12 hour
workdays.
You know,
they're,
they're working a few different jobs just to provide for their families who hell
is going to go home after a long day of work.
Sit down and read all of these news stories much less understand the nuance of
these new stories.
That's a difficult thing to do and it's a lot to ask of the American people.
But the way that you can fix that is by creating a media,
a form of media that is informative with no corporate interests.
Because right now the gold standard of news is still the MSNBC,
CNN,
Fox News.
It's the stuff that you just turn on you,
you watch it in the background while you're trying to feed your kids and take
care of your family.
And that's problematic because a lot of those networks will spread
misinformation or they have a particular agenda.
And as a result,
they will only cover the news that fits their agenda.
And there's an issue with that.
But hopefully new media will grow to the point where it'll take over that system
and it'll,
you know,
educate people enough to where they will want to stand up for their rights and
they will want to be politically active.
I'm teaching a class at cal state Northridge right now.
It's a journalism class.
Prepare for stalkers.
Cockers are coming.
I have a private security.
It'll be fine.
Um,
double up on that now.
and I remember when I first started teaching the class,
I asked every single one of the students to tell me what they find most
interesting in media.
What do they want to cover,
what's their beat?
And the vast majority of them were like entertainment,
news,
sports,
you know,
stuff that's really easy to cover.
And very profitable.
So I don't blame them for wanting to do that.
But I wanted to instill in them a type of intellectual curiosity where they
would want to know about what's going on in the political world,
where they would want to be these mini political activists.
And I don't do it in,
in the sense that I tell them,
hey,
you gotta be progressive.
I definitely shy away from that,
but I want them to look at news stories critically and question the way that
they're being covered.
So that's like my little tiny bit of trying to make a difference.
And I love doing that.
Being a,
an instructor at a university is a very thankless job.
I've learned that this semester since it's my first time doing it.
But you gotta,
you gotta start by,
you know,
changing the way people learn about journalism,
changing the way they cover stories and you got to get people to be critical
thinkers.
Okay.
Or at least tried to inspire them to be,
I mean,
it's just really tough to get someone to do anything.
It is,
it is,
it is tough.
But I will say I open every class with a production meeting,
like we do mock production meetings similar to what you would do in a newsroom.
And the type of stories that they pitch now are very different from what they
started pitching in the beginning of the semester.
So they're way more politically minded,
which I love.
All of a sudden they're bringing up the Glenn Greenwald,
Edward Snowden type stories and I'm like,
yes.
Like that's a little bit of a difference and it makes me very happy.
Happy.
Do you feel like,
because I mean you do this for a living,
but do you think that you can even keep up with all the shit that's happening on
a daily basis?
No.
Have a regular person.
It's difficult.
How can they,
I mean it's,
it's almost impossible to
be informed today.
It's almost impossible.
And it truly informed,
I think.
I don't,
I don't think it's impossible.
I think it's overwhelming,
but I don't think it's impossible as a responsibility.
How much do you have a responsibility to be informed?
Not You,
but like a regular person with a regular job and a family and God forbid if you
have a fucking hobby.
But if you're working on something during the day,
what are the odds that you can pay attention to the top 10 news stories of the
day and form of really clear opinion on any of them.
It's very difficult.
We're fucked too many hours,
but you know what?
Here's the thing and I'm going to,
people are not going to like what I'm about to say.
Oh everyone loves distractions.
Like how much time do we spend on social media?
How much time do we spend watching reality shows and doing things that we want
to do?
Cause we just want to shut our brains off.
We want to numb ourselves to what's going on in the world,
right?
Instead of doing that,
maybe we should change the culture.
So people will want to use that very precious time and that very precious
resource,
uh,
to be informed.
They want to use it for that as opposed to being,
you know,
I think distracted problem that people have with being informed over being
distracted is that it's incredibly frustrating and you feel helpless when you
start reading all these stories about the stock market manipulations about the
banks being bailed out and about bailouts where the fucking people that were
involved in the bail out somehow or another warranted some crazy commission.
They got some bonus of the gut and then the president said is going to limit to
a half a million dollars.
He's like a fucking half a million dollars is a lot of money,
man.
What do you mean you're limiting it to a half of them?
Didn't we just give them a ton of money?
You feel helpless when you read about this shit over and over and over again.
When you watched documentaries on fracking,
when you,
you know,
you read stories in the news about how,
how poorly veterans are being taken care of when they come back from war and
there's so many different things that you read where it doesn't make sense.
I know,
but when you look at all of these new stories,
there's always one underlying issue in every new story.
It's kind of amazing and it always goes back to who is funding these
politicians,
right?
If you get the money out of politics,
that virus,
if you destroy that virus,
things will change quickly because our representatives will be forced to pay
attention to the American people,
the people that are voting for them as opposed to the people who are paying
them.
You know,
if you get rid of that type of bribery that we're dealing with right now,
the entire system needs to be changed,
unquestionably.
But how does that ever happen?
I mean,
it doesn't mean we,
you have to like get them to change it themselves as well.
How else is it going to get changed?
Here's the thing.
Um,
Congress is obviously very corrupt.
So Congress,
this is America there obviously I'm very much bought by corporations and as a
result,
it's really difficult for them to propose any real change.
But when it comes to the state level,
when it comes to state legislators,
it's a little different.
So we actually managed to get,
I'm
a state representative from Texas to propose a resolution for a constitutional
convention.
And it goes back to what I was saying earlier about wolf pack.
And if we get,
you know,
state state representatives from all the states to agree to this constitutional
convention,
then we can actually have this constitutional amendment to get money out of
politics.
It's possible.
We just need to inform people about it.
wolf-pack.wolf-pack.com
get on it.
Well,
I hope you're right and I,
I'm,
I'm very hopeful.
I just,
I think that it's incredibly difficult to get venom out of the system and then
once,
once it's in there,
it's in there pretty deep.
It's going to be very hard to heal this poisoned system.
And the people that are accustomed extracting money,
they,
they mean that's a giant part of their motivation for being in the position when
they're in,
in the first place.
Yeah.
Now all of a sudden they're there and they can extract money anymore.
Then you gotta go,
why kind of Hippie bullshit is this?
All of a sudden they're going to have to pay attention to the people that voted
for them.
That's crazy.
They get to a point where they can't do that anymore.
I think that's one of the things that we need is we need new young politicians.
I think that's hugely,
hugely important.
Until that happened,
and principled politicians,
I mean you'll have some Paul,
some candidates who will run a campaign and they're genuine in how they want to
change the system.
I think Obama is an example of that.
I think he was genuine to begin with and then they enter the system and they're
corrupted by what we have to deal with.
They're corrupted by the money in politics and I mean,
what are you going to do?
At the end of the day,
you got to,
you got to run for reelection.
You need the funds,
right,
and you're going to get the funds from corporations and then you have to
basically get down on your knees and do whatever the corporation's need you to
do.
That's my opinion.
I'm with you on this,
but I talked to Sam Harris who I respect very greatly and his opinion is very
different.
He believes that there's so many dangerous people in the world that Obama got
into office then immediately realized how fucking scary the world is and then
started tightening down drone attacks,
cut,
cut down on sort of,
I mean it started,
uh,
cut down on whistle blowers,
surveillance ups,
all,
all the things that he did once he got into office,
that what explains that has reversed on Guantanamo Bay.
He believes that it's because the stack of papers that he gets on his desk every
day of memos,
telling them what's been avoided,
what,
how fucked up the world is,
what dangers we're facing on a regular basis,
who we need to attack before the attack us.
That they're just trying to avoid another lot,
nine 11.
I don't know if I'm really buying that argument.
I think that we have this military industrial complex and I think that Obama
does not want to seem weak when it comes to national security.
So as a result he will do things that are extreme.
I mean,
if you're really concerned about national security,
it's very curious for you to go about keeping the country safe by causing so
much hostility toward the u s think about that we are bombing and doing drone
strikes on innocent civilians abroad that creates hostility toward the United
States that makes people want to attack us.
So,
I mean,
I,
I'm not really buying that.
You know,
Obama got in and he got scared.
I think that people are making money off what's going on abroad right now.
And I,
I,
I think that Obama is worried about seeming weak to Republicans.
I mean,
when you look at almost all of his policies,
he's always been so afraid of Republican's,
which drives me crazy.
The only thing that he's really had a good stance on was gay marriage.
And that was after what years of being president.
He finally came out and said,
yeah,
I guess I've changed my mind.
Civil unions aren't enough.
We should have same sex marriage.
Well,
if you really believe that,
then we should do something on the federal level.
This is not a states' rights issue.
This is a federal issue.
This is a civil rights issue.
I feel like gay rights and gay marriage is one of those beach ball they toss up
at a concert,
totally has to keep in the air because it keeps everybody distracted.
Gay Marriage,
oh no more tone.
And they keep bouncing this stupid beach ball around
and the and politicians are now using it for political gain,
which is really frustrating.
You know what I mean?
It's,
Oh look,
it turns out that,
you know,
the majority of Americans are in favor of gay rights.
So let's change our stance on that.
There's,
they're not principled.
And in,
in that case it's a good thing because I want gay rights,
but I just,
politicians will be politicians,
you know,
and,
and a lot of them lack,
well,
it's always been said that they're like,
it's like politics are show business for ugly people and actors are notorious
for sticking their finger in the air and finding out which way the wind blows
culturally and then saying things that they don't necessarily believe in or
necessarily have even researched.
And that's hugely common when you're on sets.
There's always these dumb Bimbo actors that have opinions and males more than
females,
Bimbo,
males,
and they'll have these opinions on something political or will the will the
Democrats won.
It was like,
what the fuck are you even talking about?
You're talking nonsense.
Did you just like read a a front page article in Salon for five seconds and now
all of a sudden you're going to tell us what's wrong with the world?
What they do is try to appear liberal.
They try to appear progressive cause they're not even human.
Yeah.
There are some weird form that like they're,
they're like a mold that like in grab human flesh and fucking fake it and they
can walk through life pretending to have regular emotions and regular feelings.
Meanwhile,
they're just trying to get people to give them the next job,
trying to get people to like them enough to cast them in the next TV show or
movie or whatever.
They're barely even alive there.
These Weirdos,
and I think politicians are very much the same way.
Obviously there's a massive generalization.
This is not all actors.
I met a lot of cool actors,
but I have met a lot of fucking Weirdos that are like Stepford wives are like
robot people.
They'll like some Weirdo who's just trying to be whatever work,
whatever pants.
Where do I have to have fake rips on my jeans?
What?
What's the new thing?
You know?
Should I wear a nose ring?
No.
Nose rings are out.
I mean,
they're on the fucking whatever the edge is.
Everyone's wearing what everybody else is wearing.
Do you remember when those von Dutch hats,
we're going around,
they had those fucking stupid trucker hats and you're like,
what are you doing?
You have a fucking stupid trucker hat on and everybody's got them.
I just thought of Ashton Kutcher.
Anytime I think of Chuck Chuck or hats,
I think of Ashton Kutcher who was young man at a time.
I don't fault him,
but I think it's that sort of a thing where you get that in politics as well.
You get a human that's not even really a human with the AR.
Is this,
this,
this thing that's leaning towards whatever Polk gravity or the wind or the,
the,
the rush of the water beneath their feet.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's pulling in one direction and the,
there's no stability is no base,
no real ethics.
And when they do have ethics,
they look fucking crazy.
They look like Ron Paul,
some,
some nutty.
Do they look like some Gary Johnson from New Mexico fringe character?
Well,
I mean,
I think there have been politicians in the past who had ethics and people will
look down on them.
Um,
but,
uh,
a perfect example of a politician that actually gets a lot of respect as
Elizabeth Warren.
If Elizabeth Warren ran for president,
I'd be like Hillary,
who,
you know,
like she's an amazing person who actually stood up to the banks when it was an
unpopular thing to do.
And also when in this current system,
it's political suicide because these are the assholes that are supposed to fund
your campaigns,
right?
So Elizabeth Warren,
you know,
is an incredible senator.
I don't think that she's actually going to run for president,
but people are becoming more and more open to principled politicians because
it's refreshing.
It's,
I mean,
when this whole rob Ford Ford thing was happening in Toronto,
there were a number of supporters because they thought that it was refreshing.
That he was so honest,
even though she's freaking crazy.
Yeah.
But they're like,
yeah,
at least he's honest.
All right.
You know,
maybe we'll vote for him again.
it's amazing.
He smoke crack.
He was pretty awesome about it.
But if you look at a guy that's that fat,
he's this giant moon face.
Like he's wild.
He's kind of deals do anything so indulgent.
He is going,
he's doing with food look good.
He's doing to his body.
You think he's scared of some crack?
That guy's not secured.
If anything,
he'll just a smoke some crack.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that one of the things that this,
this shift that's happening with information,
one of the things it's going to be very fascinating about this erosion of
privacy is that you're going to get real honest politicians because they have no
choice.
Exactly.
You know what's amazing though is you'll have politicians that are on the record
saying one thing and then like a few months later they back pedal or they say
something or flip flop and they say something completely different and they
denied that they did a flip flop and it's like,
like Mitt Romney's an example of that.
There was evidence indicating that Mitt Romney supported planned parenthood and
then when he was running for president,
he's like,
I will shut planned parenthood down.
It's like you're on the record,
dude.
There's evidence.
Like how are you unaware of the Internet
and how it holds you accountable to what you've done and said in the past?
Well,
Mim Romney's still in denial that he's a first generation Mexican.
Yeah.
He's still in denial of his family living over in Mexico.
You remember who was talking about that like very briefly during the,
uh,
the,
the campaign that his father actually was born in Mexico and everybody was like,
what?
And then you get deep into when you're fine.
Like,
Oh,
your dad was in a sex cult.
Oh
Wow.
Mitt Romney was a character.
He still is.
Yeah.
He was the governor of Massachusetts for a long time.
People loved them.
Did a good job.
Some people loved them.
Yeah.
I mean he,
his colleague,
he had healthcare in Massachusetts.
It's very similar to the affordable care act and then he went off and started
criticizing the affordable care act.
It's like amazing to me.
Yeah.
He would have fucked up as soon as he got an office too.
I think all of them,
once they get in there,
they just,
they just get taken down.
You know,
they,
they get sat down and they get spelled out how the world really works and they
probably have hints of it before they actually get in there.
But once they get in there and they meet with the fucking Bilderberg group and
they meet with the international bankers that control the world's economy and
they just realize the,
the depth of the puzzle,
it's probably,
I mean that's why they all go gray like instantly.
Oh yeah.
Oklahoma has aged so much.
It's kind of incredible.
When it'd be amazing if he did like an Eisenhower type for like,
like a final speech when Eisenhower warned of the uh,
the military industrial complex.
If,
if Obama,
all these,
yeah.
If Obama warned about the military does no callbacks,
that would be very funny
if he got on TV and just said,
listen,
I've been bullshitting you people for eight years.
Like this system is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Move to Canada.
That would be move to Hawaii.
I'm going back there too.
He never would though.
I mean even though he doesn't have to worry about getting reelected again,
Democrats are holding him accountable.
They don't want to look bad because they want to make sure another Democrat gets
elected and it's all,
it's all bs.
It's the same as long as our system is dealing with that virus.
As long as our system has the money in politics,
it doesn't matter if you're voting for a Democrat or Republican,
it's the same.
At the end of the day,
they might be different with social issues.
They might be a little different when it comes to fiscal policy.
Although Obama is not a good example of him being,
you know,
different when it comes to fiscal policy.
Um,
they're not different when it comes to international policy.
I'm a little happier when a Democrats in office because of what I think they do
socially when it comes to things like gay marriage or,
yeah.
Things like right to choose.
And the thing that,
things along those lines,
I feel like when the,
when you have a Republican in office,
those things tend to get squashed.
Yeah.
And I think that's one of the benefits of having a Democrat in office is the get
more quality,
especially when you're dealing with a,
a Democrat who also happens to be black.
I think it's good socially,
but then when you look at what he's done in comparison to what Bush has,
it's,
man,
it's
real similar.
Yeah.
Like it's hard to tell the difference between a Democrat and a Republican other
than the healthcare issue,
which seems to be a cluster fuck.
But I would imagine everything that you get started from scratch as a
clusterfuck.
I don't know why anybody would think that.
It wouldn't be a cluster.
Fuck.
I look,
the one thing that I just don't understand is why everyone's panicking about the
website.
The website keeps crashing.
It's not worth whatever it,
they'll figure it out.
It'll get the porn guys to figure it out.
Those guys get 6 billion hits a day.
They're up.
That's their problem.
That's the problem that the Obama administration didn't think about.
They just hired the wrong people should hire porn people.
What was the last time you went to a porn website and it crashed because too
many people were on it.
That shit never happens.
I'm not saying that you go to porn websites,
but I'm saying anybody out there perverts you weirdos.
If you've ever gone to one and you found out that it's too many people on the
server crashed,
that doesn't happen.
They figured out how to make that work and I guarantee you way more people are
going to a porn site then are going to any government side,
whether it's Obamacare or Medicare or whatever,
name the site.
So the,
the,
the one thing that I will agree on in terms of it being a cluster fuck is only
50,000 Americans have signed up through the website.
Um,
which could be disastrous because in order for the affordable care act to work,
you need people to sign up.
I have doubled down on my Instagram page pitch.
Do you that's amazing.
No,
it's not that much.
There's people with millions by more than a million on Twitter.
That's the most places I have a Twitter.
I think I have a ton of followers on Twitter.
1,175,682 bananas a lot.
I think I have like 40 but I'm sure a lot of them are fake.
I have never paid for any that are fake,
but there's a lot of bots out there and a lot of people that use a,
they use fake Twitter accounts,
slate things.
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to like pretend as if I'm like a big superstar or something.
There's a lot of people that have done it though.
It's pretty common.
Apparently.
It's pretty easy to do.
You just pay some money and they get you x amount of fake followers for,
I think for some people it gives them some sort of a confirmation that they're
okay and they said he's got 25,000 Twitter followers.
He must be legit.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
It's so funny because,
um,
you know,
going back to the class that I'm teaching,
one of my students looked me up and she's like,
Holy Shit,
you have all these followers and you're verified.
I'm like,
Oh,
does that make me more legitimate now?
Because I have like a verified Twitter account,
but people think it's a big deal.
It's really funny.
Yeah,
it's big.
It's big.
If someone says,
hey man,
I want to come with your podcast,
and I go to their page and they have 212 Twitter followers,
I'm like,
bitch,
you,
you looked at my Twitter page.
I got to senior show as soon as you are legit.
Okay,
good.
I didn't,
uh,
didn't go to your Twitter page,
but we can go there right now.
What do you got?
How much you got?
Let me check this out.
I think 42,000 is that a lot?
I don't think so.
I think that's decent.
How long you've been on the young Turks?
Oh Gosh.
For seven years.
Yeah.
That's not enough.
You need more Twitter followers,
which I'm stronger last.
Yeah,
for sure.
Did I take the titty pictures of you?
Oh,
you don't have to go to a titty.
Take some pictures with like you,
uh,
like in a bikini,
like looking over your shoulder,
you know,
at your Bot.
Those are huge.
Just one of those probably get you,
you know,
you don't want to do that.
Obviously people out there was screaming at me right now.
This is why we need feminism.
That's how I was like you
do you get shit for saying that you a,
you don't like radical feminism.
Do you ever get people angry at you for,
no.
The funny thing is a lot of people think that I am a radical feminist,
which I'm not.
Any girl that's smart is a feminist,
instantly did skin.
It's really funny.
I'm,
I'm actually,
I think the word feminism is tainted at this point and I would much rather refer
to myself as a gender equality specialists,
specialists,
whatever.
I mean,
whatever you want to call it,
because look,
men get the short end of the stick when it comes to some serious issues.
Women get the short end of the stick when it comes to serious issues.
I don't like the brand of feminism that tells me that I can't be feminine.
I fucking hate that.
Like I want to wear my dresses and I want to feel sexy and beautiful and I want
to push for equality.
You can do that.
Those things are not mutually exclusive,
so that's just an example.
If you look like Fred Flintstone,
you don't like wearing makeup,
they probably will be exclusive.
Yeah,
well it's,
I think it's one of those things where there's certain people that don't want
other people behaving differently than them,
especially if they feel like they're being judged by the fact that you're
wearing makeup and you have heels on and they don't like that.
Then they get judged.
Well.
Then they start turning that at against you.
Instead of saying,
look,
hey,
it's different strokes for different folks.
Some people like this,
some people like that.
Instead of that,
they look to you like you're some sort of a trader.
Meanwhile,
those same people,
if it was a man that was wearing makeup and wearing a dress wearing high heels,
they would go,
you go girl,
they would,
there would be happy for you.
Cause that's the progressive move.
If it's a transgender person that a man who became a woman and wants to wear
long nails and wants to like be really dainty and feminine,
that's all well and groovy.
Yeah.
But when a woman is dainty and feminine,
exactly.
Yeah,
it'd be hilarious.
The argument that they'll make is,
well if you don't want to be objectified,
then don't objectify yourself.
I don't find it objectifying.
Just because I'm wearing something that's considered sexy doesn't mean that I'm
asking people to objectify me in.
If people do,
then that's on them.
Like it's,
it's kind of like saying,
you know,
if a woman dresses sexy,
then she deserves to get raped.
She should expect to get raped,
right?
No.
Like a woman who dresses sexy,
you shouldn't expect someone to do anything.
I don't think you should expect to get objectified ever.
And what is the,
what does objectify even mean that someone,
if someone is attracted to you physically,
are they objectifying you if they want to look at you while they have sex with
you or they objectifying you?
Like what?
When they find you sexy,
at what point?
What did,
where's the gradient?
Like what's the spectrum?
Right.
Where it falls into objectification of women if you're not profiting off of her.
Are you objecting w objectifying?
Like what?
What,
where's the gray area?
It's a kind of a strange thing.
If someone likes the way you look in a dress or they objectifying you,
it's like how was that objectifying?
It's,
it's a just a fashion sense or it's just an aesthetic.
and it's,
it's stupid to pretend as if women don't objectify men as well.
I did it the other day when I went on a hike and it was like a ton of hot guys
without their shirts on people.
It's human nature to objectify.
I don't like that word.
I think it's you're admiring,
you're attracted to it.
So what does objectify,
you want to turn them into an object that means dehumanizing them.
It means removing the humanity and use them as a fuck toy.
But that's not what you're looking to do.
That that's not what you're looking to do.
You are physically attracted to someone and that's the first thing that stands
out to you.
I think that it becomes wrong when that's all you see in the person,
right.
When that's all that matters to you and you know someone's level of intellect or
character means nothing.
You know what?
I don't even think that's wrong.
No.
I think if you're nice to each other and you're just like dating people that are
really pretty,
who gives a shit?
What am I supposed to be upset at you if you have dumb friends?
No,
but when you fuck dumb people,
I'm supposed to get a mad.
Can't you do better?
Maybe it doesn't want to do better.
Maybe he likes being around dumb friends,
maybe likes having a dumb girlfriend or a dumb boyfriend who do I give a shit?
I don't care what Pete,
what other people do.
I don't want to be looked upon that way.
Like I don't want people to look at me and say like,
oh,
she's just a pretty face and nothing more than that one's going to do that
unless they're trying to define you.
I mean,
you know better than that.
How dare you?
I dare you play that game.
That's not gonna fly.
Yeah.
I think there's also an issue where,
um,
people,
they,
they feel uncomfortable if they're not there.
They're not seen as attractive.
And so they tried to squash other things that people think are attractive.
They tried to,
like,
they just try to be little attempts at being attractive.
I mean,
I think that there's an issue in that as well.
If there wasn't an issue in that.
And if you are a type of person that likes wearing chuck Taylors and loose jeans
and t shirts,
what do you care if a woman is wearing a bikini right?
Beach,
what do you care if someone wears a mini skirt?
Like w how does that affect you?
It doesn't affect you,
I think,
you know,
competition,
jealousy,
all of that kind of plays a role in that as well.
It exposes Douche bags.
It's excellent that,
you know,
exposes asshole men.
I mean,
yeah,
you put yourself in a vulnerable position.
If you'll walk around like wearing a bikini and you're walking down main street
and you know,
fucking high heels on,
you're going to run into a lot of weird people.
Just kind of given them a green light to get freaky with you or at least going
to look good.
You boom you owned were,
yeah.
It's weird way to end it.
I think we'd have to time a three,
three hours in,
we turn into a pumpkin.
Um,
this was a great show.
I really enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it too.
It was a lot of fun.
I got to know you.
Yeah.
I hope.
I hope they liked me.
They liked to you according to Twitter and their peers.
That's awesome.
Just one last shout out to Robert.
You have a lot of fans that are like you gotta give me a shout out.
Robert in Miami,
Robert in Miami.
Go Fuck Yourself,
dude.
How dare you.
Just kidding Robert.
Uh,
thank you to our sponsors.
Thanks to legal zoom.
Use the code word Rogan in the referral box and save yourself some cash,
son.
Thanks.
Also to stamps.com use the code word j r e and get your $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 with free postage.
Go get it,
girl.
And we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t used code named Rogan's.
Save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
We will be back tomorrow with the Great Graham Hancock,
one of my personal favorite human beings that has ever walked the face of the
earth.
He's a an awesome guy with an alternative view of human history and you're going
to love the shit out of it.
All right,
we love you.
Bye Bye.